An SCP Foundation researcher sits at a table
inside of a standard containment cell.
These are often dangerous places to be, especially
when the SCP you’re supposed to be studying
is one that you can’t see.
The researcher is taking notes, unsure of
exactly what’s going to happen next.
He can hear the sounds of knives scraping
behind, of flesh sizzling and searing from
high heat.
He braces himself as a burst of heat hits
the back of his head, as if a fireball has
erupted.
Just then it happens - an object floats through
the air and settles in front of him on the
table.
It’s a plate of food, and it looks delicious.
It may surprise you to learn that there is
no rule that the SCP Foundation must deal
exclusively with violent and vicious creatures.
Not every SCP held in containment shares the
same malevolence and contempt for humanity
as SCP-682, or the world-ending threat posed
by the likes of SCP-2317.
Some - perhaps not many, but some - are benign
and might even seem outwardly friendly, but
you’d still be taking a huge risk to assume
that anything contained by the SCP Foundation
is completely harmless.
Such is the case with SCP-5031.
As per the Foundation’s containment procedures,
this quasi-humanoid – meaning it appears
to have some vaguely human features - is held
in an airtight cell that is regularly checked
by Foundation personnel on a bi-weekly basis.
SCP-5031 has no need for regular nutrition
or regular interactions from staff.
The trick with SCP-5031, is not being eaten
by it, since though it doesn’t need food,
it does still hunt and consume anything it
encounters - human or otherwise.
Avoiding being eaten is hard enough with creatures
that can actually be seen, but like so many
other creatures the Foundation keeps contained,
SCP-5031 has developed an almost-perfect defense
mechanism - which is that when observed, it
will literally cease to exist.
Some might choose to refer to this as a ‘quantum
lock’, however it is worth noting that traces
left by SCP-5031 still remain observable when
the creature has temporarily disappeared.
For example, trails of blood and scratch marks
left behind by SCP-5031 still exist when the
SCP itself does not.
Naturally, this makes both avoiding the creature
and capturing it using cameras difficult.
However, when SCP-5031’s existence ceases
it still casts a shadow.
From this, researchers have been able to determine
several of the creature’s physical traits.
Based on its silhouette, it has been deduced
that SCP-5031 levitates about half a meter
above ground level, it sports an abnormally
small, neckless head atop an elongated torso
- approximately 1.9 meters long - with three
sets of spindly lower arms that branch outwards.
Using these arms and its loosely hanging body,
SCP-5031 will lower itself to hunt any human
or animal that draws near to it and uses the
bladelike tail to cut up food.
Perhaps the most interesting facet of SCP-5031
beyond its defensive capabilities and apparent
physical attributes, are the series of nine
tests conducted by Senior Researcher Stanley
Huxtable.
Appalled by the conditions that the creature
was being kept in, Huxtable took over the
role of HCL Supervisor for SCP-5031.
Having grown increasingly
frustrated and empathetic
towards the creature, listening to its screams
from inside its iron containment unit, Huxtable
devised a series of tests to introduce SCP-5031
to various different stimuli as a way to better
understand the creature and hopefully keep
it contained in a way that didn’t seem to
cause so much suffering.
It's worth remembering that the SCP Foundation
makes it its mission to be cold, not cruel,
in performing their duties to protect normality
and many of the researchers and staff are
just as capable of having empathy for creatures
as you might for a stray animal at a shelter.
The first of Huxtable’s tests involved installing
speakers in SCP-5031’s cell, through which
a variety of different ambient and popular
pieces of music were played to see if they
had any effect on reducing the creature’s
stress.
By judging SCP-5031’s stress levels based
on how much it screamed when compared to normal,
Huxtable was able to determine how to best
to use music to calm the creature.
SCP-5031 seemed to convey higher levels of
stress when listening to ‘Morning Forest’,
‘Deep Grotto’ and ‘Seaside Paradise’
ambience, as well as the best of late 60s
British rock band Jethro Tull.
However, the best of Mozart, Enya, KISS and
Ben Folds produced dramatically different
results, decreasing SCP-5031’s apparent
stress.
Following this test, Senior Researcher Huxtable
compiled a playlist featuring SCP-5031’s
favorite music.
Over time, the stress-reducing effects of
music on SCP-5031 seemed to decrease, but
keeping the playlist on shuffle seemed to
keep the creature consistently calmer than
it had been previously.
The next test involved introducing inanimate
objects into SCP-5031’s enclosure to monitor
its reactions and how its stress levels were
affected.
When a softball was thrown into the enclosure,
SCP-5031 immediately sliced the ball in two
with its tail in one swift motion.
A similar result occurred when researchers
threw the creature a basketball, which was
quickly punctured and sliced open by SCP-5031’s
tail.
Its stress levels first seemed to diminish
when the creature was offered a bowling ball,
which it rolled around the enclosure and then
later knocked against a second bowling ball.
However, when one of the balls chipped, rendering
it unable to roll properly, SCP-5031’s stress
increased dramatically, until a replacement
was offered.
Researcher Huxtable noted that SCP-5031 seemed
to possess a similar level of motor skills
to an average human toddler, with similarly
explosive emotional reactions to match.
Next, when given the choice between two food
sources at opposite ends of its enclosure,
SCP-5031 seemed to gravitate
towards higher-quality
food, most notably favoring cooked rotisserie
chickens over animal carcasses.
It even chose this option over a live chicken,
using its tail to cut its
food into more manageable
bite-sized portions, rather than ripping its
meat with its hands or teeth like many of
its fellow SCPs.
Researcher Huxtable recorded these findings
and highlighted that, even though SCP-5031
didn’t need to eat in order to survive,
providing the creature with food of a better
quality marginally reduced its stress.
Senior Researcher Huxtable next attempted
to test SCP-5031’s coexistence with other
living subjects, each time making sure that
the creature had been adequately fed to avoid
any unseemly incidents.
First, a live chicken was introduced.
SCP-5031 rolled its bowling ball at high speed
towards the chicken, increasing both its and
the chicken’s stress levels, and inadvertently
killing the chicken in the process.
When a second chicken was introduced, SCP-5031
gently rolled a basketball towards it but
ceased any further engagement after the chicken
squawked from being hit by the ball.
Next to be introduced into the enclosure was
a blindfolded D Class staff member, who was
instructed to sit down and roll the basketball
towards SCP-5031.
After doing so for several minutes, the creature
began to approach the D class subject, who
was instructed to remove their blindfold to
cease the creature’s existence and prevent
any potentially deadly incidents.
Finally, Researcher Huxtable had another Class-D
engage in a game of catch with SCP-5031 while
facing away from the creature.
This test proceeded successfully, and Senior
Researcher Huxtable remarked how SCP-5031’s
motor skills were improving.
Albeit gradually, and with
some gentle encouragement,
through Huxtable’s tests the creature was
learning.
The next test, focused on teaching SCP-5031
linguistic symbols, utilized LCD displays
and buttons connected to a food dispenser.
One display showed an image of a rock, and
the other an image of a rotisserie chicken.
After some brief probing, SCP-5031 was quickly
able to understand that pressing the button
under the correct display would dispense a
rotisserie chicken for it to eat.
The creature was later able to adapt when,
the following day, the screen displays and
materials dispensed were swapped, and then
later set to swap at random intervals.
When additional rock-dispensing stations were
introduced, this time displaying the word
‘rock’ as opposed to an image, SCP-5031
was able to determine which station dispensed
‘chicken’ through a process of elimination.
Whenever the functions and displays were swapped,
SCP-5031 would find whichever displayed the
word ‘chicken’ to receive its food.
The final phase of this test presented SCP-5031
with a single station, displaying the word
‘chicken’, but with a button that would
remain inactive unless the creature spelled
out the same word with a collection of lettered
blocks it was provided with.
After some initial confusion and frustration
as to why the button would not dispense food
when pressed, SCP-5031 was able to assemble
the word correctly, not only activating the
button and dispensing food, but proving to
Researcher Huxtable that the creature was
capable of learning language.
Huxtable continued to test
the creature, encouraging
it to spell words using lettered blocks as
a method of communicating.
By increasing SCP-5031’s vocabulary and
the amount of human interaction it received,
Senior Researcher Huxtable observed that SCP-5031
was gradually learning to
sing - albeit nonverbally
- as well as to juggle with its six hands
and was even communicating
its own food preferences
and dish pairings.
Later, another Class-D, D-52125, was introduced
to SCP-5031’s enclosure to aid in further
testing.
Through D-52125’s instructions, the creature
quickly learned to draw using crayons, and
created artworks depicting itself, its newfound
friend D-52125, Researcher Huxtable, a cat
and a rotisserie chicken.
SCP-5031’s new creative side didn’t stop
there though, as the creature quickly learned
to play Chopsticks in only two days once a
piano was introduced into the enclosure.
SCP-5031 even managed to start creating its
own original, admittedly crude, compositions.
Next, a spice rack was
placed inside the creature’s
cell and D-52125 demonstrated how to season
meat.
This proved to be SCP-5031’s new favorite
hobby, as it spent the next
three days experimenting
with different combinations of foods and spices,
using its letter blocks to request ‘more,
more, more’ garlic powder.
Interestingly, the creature only created artwork
or music when D-52125 was present, but seemed
to thoroughly enjoy its experimentation with
food when left alone.
Following this development, Senior Researcher
Huxtable devised a new test for SCP-5031.
Providing the creature with cooking utensils
and using D-52125 to demonstrate, 5031 was
shown how to prepare a variety of different
dishes, from hamburgers and tacos, to Mongolian
Beef, steak, clam chowder and profiteroles.
In addition to a small peanut allergy, this
eighth test revealed SCP-5031 to be a phenomenal
chef, possessing culinary skills far beyond
the average person.
The creature quickly and enthusiastically
embraced its newfound talents, concocting
its very own brand-new recipes, with D-52125
even volunteering to be the first to taste
test 5031’s dishes.
It was shortly after this test that SCP-5031
spoke its very first word, and it should come
as no surprise that the word was ‘salt’.
Naturally, Senior Researcher Huxtable was
very proud of the progress the creature had
made with its development.
The final test almost seemed to be what the
creature was born for.
Over the course of two months, SCP-5031 was
tasked with creating a full three-course meal
which would then be served to Foundation staff
for Thanksgiving.
SCP-5031 not only rose to the task, but exceeded
all of Researcher Huxtable’s expectations,
creating a meal that even Gordon Ramsey would
be hard pressed to find fault with.
The creature created a first course consisting
of sweet potato miso soup seasoned with turmeric.
Next came a beautiful duck confit, glazed
luxuriously with apple cider and topped generously
with sweet cranberry compote, paired with
a side of butternut squash gnocchi and served
on a bed of kale seasoned with truffle salt.
The grand finale of the exquisite meal was
a spiced cassava pie for dessert, complemented
with the finest French vanilla ice cream and
a maple-hazelnut syrup.
And SCP-5031 didn’t stop there, the creature
also debuted one of its
original musical compositions
to compliment the decadent meal it had created.
As the staff enjoyed the food, SCP-5031 performed
live from its enclosure the deeply moving
Piano Concerto for Six Hands, to an overwhelmingly
positive response from not only Senior Researcher
Huxtable, but the entire Foundation staff.
As a fitting end to the creature’s tale,
Huxtable reported that, during the Thanksgiving
banquet it had created, SCP-5031’s stress
levels reduced entirely.
New kinder containment measures that would
keep 5031 safer but also far more contented
were submitted for approval.
Perhaps some of you may find it refreshing
to learn that SCP-5031 isn’t simply just
another malicious, malevolent monster that
the Foundation has to keep under lock and
key for the safety of the world.
Instead, SCP-5031 is a gentle – if a little
frightening at first creature - that just
requires careful and considered guidance instead
of a cold iron cage and around-the-clock armed
guards.
Through testing, Senior Researcher Stanley
Huxtable and his fellow Foundation staff were
not only able to help the creature develop,
but also found what makes it tick; and not
just for the purposes of containing it.
Instead, it is hoped that SCP-5031’s creativity
and flair for culinary and musical masterpieces
can continue to thrive and grow, under the
proud watch of Researcher Huxtable.
A veteran worker of the SCP Foundation sits
at his terminal, performing one of the most
critical tasks in the entire organization
- creating a file for an as yet undescribed
SCP.
But there’s something terribly wrong.
His eyes are glazed over, his mouth hangs
open - is this a zombie or a trained foundation
researcher?
What is going on?
Like any large international organization,
it takes more than just the exciting, action
filled jobs to keep the wheels turning at
the SCP Foundation.
Sure, the head researchers, guards, mobile
task force soldiers, and members of the O5
Command get all the praise, but a legion of
number crunchers, cleaners, and paper pushers
are equally important.
One such person was archivist Walter Bainbridge,
who had been tasked with digitizing some of
the older records that the Foundation had
on file.
It was when he was innocently recording the
details on SCP - 050 through 060 that he first
came under the strange and startling effects
of SCP - 055.
But, the most peculiar
part, as with all incidences
of SCP - 055’s anomalous effects taking
hold, is that Walter had no idea any of it
was happening.
In his new digitized filing system, he first
took note of SCP - 053.
Euclid Class, also known as the Young Girl,
this anomaly was a seemingly normal human
female child who provoked homicidal insanity
in those directly exposed to her.
Then SCP - 054.
Safe Class, a non-aggressive humanoid female
made entirely of, as well as biologically
and chemically identical to regular spring
water.
Next, SCP - 056.
Euclid Class, a being that changes form to
suit its environment, but only when all observers
lose focus on it.
And then SCP - 057.
Safe Class, an underground chamber that crushes
the humans who walk within.
It was at this point that Walter received
a concerned message from one of his superiors
at Site-19, Mr. Kovach.
The message praised the thorough digitization
of the other anomalies’ records, but was
confused about why Walter had left out any
mention of SCP - 055.
Immediately, Walter was embarrassed.
How could he have forgotten SCP - 055?
That iconic anomaly known for...Well, he couldn’t
quite say, off the top of his head, but he’d
be sure to look into it.
A quick trip to the Site 19 Archives showed
him that there was actually quite a hefty
file on the nature of SCP - 055, which must
have been the result of a huge number of studies.
What struck him as strange was that all the
files were filled out in pen rather than being
typed up, like a traditional file.
The majority of these notes were written in
short-hand, too, as though they were frantically
taken during the tests themselves on extremely
short notice.
There weren’t even any redactions.
Walter made a mental note of what he had seen,
put the file back in its proper place, and
headed back to his computer terminal.
However, after writing in an almost trancelike
state, he looked back on his work to see that
he had written an entry on SCP - 058, a giant,
evil bovine heart with insect legs and a scorpion
stinger…
Strange, he thought.
That’s when Walter got a call from Mr. Kovach
on his Foundation-issue phone, and he didn’t
sound happy.
He’d given Walter direct instructions to
go back and digitize the files on 055, and
instead, he’d been working on 058.
What was the meaning of this?
Walter was typically an extremely loyal and
diligent employee, but the verbal barrage
from his supervisor had him considering talking
back, just this once, and hoping it didn’t
get him demoted to D-Class and thrown into
682’s acid bath for play time.
Walter gulped, picked up some courage, and
interrupted Mr. Kovach’s rant to ask if
he had any idea what SCP - 055 actually was.
The line went silent for a moment, then the
supervisor spoke again, this time with less
confidence.
“Of course I can tell you about SCP - 055.
It’s a classic, one of the first hundred.
How could you forget its...Or, um, you know,
its...I think it’s the one with the...”
Another long pause, as Mr. Kovach seemed to
search for the words, but instead just trailed
off into silence.
Knowing that some of the anomalies on file
were dangerous memetic hazards, Walter was
worried for a moment that he may have accidentally
killed his boss by getting him to think too
hard about SCP - 055.
He asked if Mr. Kovach was okay, and finally
got a reply.
“I’m sorry, I seem to have zoned out for
a second there.
What were we talking about, again?”
But this time, it was Walter who couldn't
answer.
He had no idea at all what the two of them
were discussing just moments ago.
He felt disoriented and kind of sick, like
they’d taken some low-level amnestics.
Mr. Kovach told Walter to get back to his
filing duties and they’d speak later.
Walter then checked the messages he’d received
from Mr. Kovach earlier, and there it was,
plain as day: “You missed 055.
Go back and digitize that before proceeding.
- Mr. K.”
But Walter had never even heard of an SCP
- 055, if such an anomaly even existed!
What was going on here?
In that moment, Walter realized he was dealing
with something much stranger than just a standard
digitization job.
After all, how could he properly complete
his duties if SCP - 055 seemed to be impossible
to speak, write, or even think about, unless
you were directly observing it at that moment?
Walter had to know, and ask around the entirety
of Site 19 to find the answers if he had to.
Sadly for Walter, he was about to embark on
a much more challenging task than he could
have ever imagined.
To paraphrase a supposed quote from Socrates,
“All I know is that I know nothing.”
And that’s also about the extent of the
knowledge we have on SCP - 055, also known
as The Anti-Meme and the Self-Keeping Secret.
What does it look like?
When and how was it obtained by the Foundation?
What are its anomalous abilities?
Is this thing dangerous?
We may never know, because the only anomalous
ability of SCP - 055 that we’re aware of
is the fact that nobody is capable of retaining
any information about it.
It’s crucial to note that, whatever 055
is, it isn’t invisible, or indescribable.
Foundation personnel are perfectly capable
of entering its containment chamber and observing
it without incident, but mere minutes after
leaving the chamber, any
memories of the particulars
of 055 seem to spontaneously erase themselves.
Hence, the Self-Keeping Secret.
But this didn’t deter Walter.
Perhaps his greatest advantage was that he
didn’t know enough about the thing he was
investigating to know how futile his mission
was.
He wanted to know the unknowable, and a pesky
issue like “impossibility” wouldn’t
stop him.
He’d get to whoever he needed to at Site
19 to get the answers he needed.
Of course most people had no knowledge of
the mysterious anomaly.
The common response he got
back from his colleagues
was, “055?
Do we even have an 055?”
While the realization of sudden memory loss
- or the realization of 055’s existence
- has been known to cause momentary stress,
there are no known long term physical or mental
effects from 055’s anomalous abilities.
It’s a fleeting idea in its purest form
- like forgetting why you walked into a room.
055 could be the most harmless object on the
Foundation’s roster, or the most deadly.
Either way, we just don’t know.
At times, Walter worried he was going insane.
055, and everything related to it, was gaslighting
him.
Was 055 even real?
The one thing that proved to him that 055
must have existed is that its containment
chamber existed.
According to the official records kept by
the Foundation on the Site 19 Containment
Facilities, 055 is kept in a “five by five
by two point five meter square room constructed
of fifty-foot-thick cement, with a Faraday
cage surrounding the cement walls.”
The report continues that, “Access is via
a heavy containment door measuring two by
two point five meters constructed on bearings
to ensure door closes and locks automatically
unless held open deliberately.”
055’s cell is one of the few to have no
posted security guards, and any personnel
working on other SCPs in the area are ordered
to remain at least fifty feet from the geometric
center of 055’s cell, where the anomaly
itself is kept.
When he tried to explore further why the cell
was constructed in this manner, he found that
- surprise, surprise - nobody knew.
055 was an anomaly whose containment requirements
were so mysterious that it automatically netted
itself a Keter Class designation.
After all, how can you properly contain something
you can’t even hope to comprehend?
There were plenty of rumors about the true
nature of 055.
Some of the more conspiratorial minds at Site
19 theorized that 055 was actually an autonomous
or remotely controlled spy inserted into the
site to observe Foundation operations - or
even humanity as a whole.
If you’re on the more paranoid end of the
psychological spectrum, this theory makes
total sense.
An anomaly that’s physically impossible
to remember, even when writings and pictures
on the subject exist, would be a perfect spy.
However, this was all ultimately little more
than speculation.
Walter was barely any further along than when
he started.
There were multiple points in his investigation
where Walter seriously considered giving up,
until, finally, he had a major breakthrough.
Dr. Bartholomew Hughes and Dr. John Marachek
were two scientists that had performed extensive
research into 055, and who - Walter hoped
- might have the answers he sought about the
Self-Keeping Secret.
These scientists were the first to discover
the “Anti-Memetic” nature of 055, performing
numerous tests on D-Class personnel to see
if it was possible to create feasible written
records, sketches, or any other records or
impressions that could bypass its anomalous
effects.
The disorienting, memory-ruining effects of
055 also extend to any materials concerning
055.
It seemed to be a truly uncrackable code,
but Dr. Hughes may have finally found some
cracks in the armor.
For starters, the fact we’re able to remember
that 055 is Anti-Memetic is an ironic exception
to its Anti-Memetic qualities.
This revelation also inspired another realization
from Dr. Hughes: Would it be possible to discover
more about 055 from the process of deduction
rather than the typical induction?
In other words, could they possibly learn
about 055 by figuring out all the things it
isn’t rather than what it is?
Dr. Marachek designed an experiment with Dr.
Hughes to explore this theory.
They designed the experiment around a simple
question: Is 055 not spherical?
In designing the question to specifically
find out what 055 isn’t, they hoped to subvert
the anomaly’s Anti-Memetic Powers.
Walter was fascinated by this potential method
of getting answers.
Marachek and Hughes found that, while the
questioning process for those exposed was
often arduous and frustrating, they could
now definitely say that 055 is not a sphere.
It is theoretically possible to discover the
true nature of 055 by an almost endless barrage
of deductive questions, though whether command
would authorize the resources for such extensive
testing is still an open question.
Walter, in his desperation, begged Marachek
and Hughes for clearance to view 055 himself.
The curiosity had become too great during
his search to just walk away with the single
fact that 055 wasn’t spherical.
He needed to see this thing.
And after several weeks of filling out forms
and cutting red tape, his wish was finally
granted.
Walter Bainbridge was allowed a private audience
with SCP - 055, the subject of his months-long
obsession.
Outsiders observed that Walter spent just
over an hour in the containment chamber, taking
photos, drawing sketches, writing down notes,
recording audio logs, and reciting memory
mnemonics.
He was pulling out every stop to counteract
the anti-memetic effects of the Self-Keeping
Secret.
He was adamant that he would not be defeated
by his non-spherical nemesis, not after all
this time and effort.
Once his time in the 055 containment chamber
was over, he retired back to his office to
finally digitize his exhaustive findings,
so that his supervisor, Mr. Kovach, would
finally get off his back.
Walter smiled, took a deep breath, and began
to type.
“SCP - 059.
Keter Class.
This anomaly is a radioactive mineral that
emits a unique radiation known as Delta Radiation.
Exposure to this radiation has caused strange
fungal growths on the infected...”
Wait, what was this supposed to be about again?
Oh well, it couldn’t have been that important.
Does the Black Moon Howl?
No. Not yet.
See the boy. He was born in a time before
names; there weren’t enough humans around
to need them back then. He was one of a handful
occupying a coastal village, using a tongue
long since dead. They eked out a simple life
- hunting, gathering, fishing. The only thing
on most of their minds was surviving to see
the next sunrise. Yes, a simple life, free
of complications.
Until The Hermit appeared.
The Boy would remember this man for an eternity.
Haggard and thin; skin weathered by time and
pain. A man that, emaciated, walking with
a long, gnarled cane that honestly looked
healthier than he did, shouldn’t be alive.
Even the Boy, who had scarcely seen beyond
the bounds of his village, knew that the Hermit
was unnatural. An aberration. An anomaly.
He walked into the center of the village,
sat down on a large stone, and waited. Nobody
dared ask his business, nor what the Hermit
waited for.
Then, a few days later, the Black Moon howled.
The Boy saw the village’s youngest hunter
freeze one evening while out on a walk. Not
simply stand still, but freeze. Then, for
an instant, he became solid black. A coal
statue. And as soon as he’d changed, he
was gone. Obliterated. Not a trace of him
remained.
Such is the power of the Black Moon. It can
make any conscious being disappear in an instant.
Turned black, then wiped from our plane of
existence, never to be seen again. Its choice
of victim seemed, at each instance, to be
utterly random, but it would come for all
who lived eventually. This is known to some
as the howling of the Black Moon.
Later that same night, the Boy found himself
talking to the Hermit, who asked with small,
frantic eyes what he had seen. When the Boy
told him, he let out a deep, rattling sigh.
The Boy, curious, asked him if he knew about
the nightmare he’d just witnessed. The Hermit
looked up. He’d been the first one, in the
Hermit’s millennia of pursuit, that had
ever asked. In that moment, he knew he had
found his successor in the hunt for the Death
of Ages.
The Hermit told the Boy it went by many names.
The Great Finale, the Pale King, but most
common of all was the Black Moon. The entity
existed beyond the veil of our reality, a
creature of pure energy, though nobody could
really be sure of its true nature. The Hermit
had been tracking it, learning about it, and
trying to destroy it for thousands of years.
And yet, it only took him four pathetic minutes
to tell the Boy everything he knew.
The Boy, knowing still that something about
the Hermit was unnatural, asked how he came
to be in this position. The Hermit told the
boy he was the Counterbalance, a kind of chosen
one, destined to face and perhaps even defeat
the Black Moon someday. The Counterbalance
receives a number of truly extraordinary gifts
for inheriting the responsibility: Eternal
life, eternal youth, near physical immortality.
But they will be haunted by their purpose,
doomed to watch everyone they love die around
them, as they continue to hunt their only
true equal and opposite, the Black Moon itself.
The Hermit, in his own eyes, had failed at
his duty. He had grown weary, and now, he
needed to pass the duty of Counterbalance
onto another. That other would be the Boy.
He felt a sudden and profound change, along
with the knowledge that nothing would ever
be the same again. He was no longer just the
Boy. Now, he was the Counterbalance.
He watched the Hermit give him a slight nod
out of respect, and then crumble into dust
before his eyes. The Boy, the Counterbalance,
looked up at the sky and saw the stars twinkling.
So bright, so beautiful. Little did he know,
his battle with the Black Moon would outlast
every single one of them.
Does the Black Moon howl? Not without blood.
The Boy grew into a man, as his village aged
and then died around him. Decades passed,
then centuries, then millennia. Tens of thousands
of years, watching humanity develop and grow
around him as he continued his pursuit of
that one elusive foe.
As science and diagnostic technology gained
ground, absorbing and then evolving beyond
all the old superstitions, the Counterbalance
gained a better understanding of the Black
Moon - though even then, it still remained
essentially a stranger. The entity was entropic,
a being of pure randomness and chaos without
consistent form. It didn’t exist in our
universe, but it could exercise its influence
here with so-called “Obliteration Events”
- much like the horrible fate that befell
the young hunter from the village.
But that was only the proverbial tip of the
iceberg.
The Counterbalance tracked and noted obliteration
events. They were exceedingly rare, at first.
Something that occurred once every thousand
years or so, like a terrible curse. But he
couldn’t help but notice a concerning trend
emerging. It started happening
once a century...then
once a decade. He could feel the terrible
future stretching out in front of him. How,
over their shared eternity, the Black Moon
would gain more and more ground.
Would there come a day where it took someone
once a year? One a month? A week, a day, an
hour, a minute, a second? It’d spell the
end of all conscious life. A total victory
for the Black Moon, the End of the Universe,
the Death of Ages. A complete existential
obliteration.
He was swept up in a sobering realization:
He couldn’t win this fight alone.
However, while his hunt for the Black Moon
had been largely fruitless, the Counterbalance
had discovered many other things along the
way, Strange creatures, objects with extraordinary
powers, and events that couldn’t be explained
with rational science. Perhaps something among
these oddities, these anomalies, would hold
the key to defeating his timeless enemy. And
it hadn’t just been these objects, entities,
and events, he’d also discovered some truly
exceptional people on his travels. Minds and
skills that rivaled even his own, despite
his age.
Perhaps they would be the ones to help him
win.
With the thirteen most brilliant and trusted
people the Counterbalance ever met, he decided
to form a Council. And from this Council,
they forged and directed an organization dedicated
to understanding and counteracting the strange
in all its forms, with the secret hope that
their search into darkness would yield the
answer to the Black Moon’s downfall.
He called it the SCP Foundation. They would
Secure the anomalous, Contain it, and Protect
all of humanity from its
influence. The Counterbalance
also took on a new title, befitting of his
new role: The Administrator. And even the
Black Moon itself was given a moniker, in
hopes of robbing it of some of its frightening
power.
SCP-001.
Does the Black Moon howl? Only at the blind.
The year was now 1987. The SCP Foundation
had been operating for over a century, and
thanks to their secret possession of anomalous
wisdom and technology, their own advancement
was thousands of years ahead of the rest of
humanity. While there still wasn’t a silver
bullet solution to the Black Moon, and its
deadly howls were becoming all the more frequent
as the decades went on, the Foundation did
have some irons in the fire to combat it.
Their ability to gather intel on both the
entity itself and its obliteration events
had improved considerably, thanks to their
new global information network. Their top
minds were also working on a highly classified
device known as the Singular Conceptual Bunker,
which may one day come in handy for combating
the extra-dimensional entity directly. But
the most valuable piece of information they
ever gathered about the Black Moon was this:
It couldn’t howl when it was being watched.
The very act of engaged observation defanged
it.
The problem is, how can you observe something
that doesn’t technically exist inside your
own reality? In order to pull this off, the
Foundation would need to get extremely creative.
Thankfully, creative solutions to strange
problems are the Foundation’s specialty.
Flash forward to 1993. Enter Dr. Moto, a brilliant
young scientist and conceptual engineer working
for the SCP Foundation. With The Administrator’s
consultation, he started the KEY Project,
an arm of the wider Project Oromasdes - the
umbrella initiative for using modified anomalous
objects in the battle against the Black Moon.
The goal of the KEY Project was relatively
simple: If people couldn’t observe the Black
Moon directly, then the Foundation could make
proxies of the Black Moon that could be observed,
almost like a kind of voodoo doll. These new
anomalies would only need to satisfy three
criteria: The inability to operate when being
observed, a hostility to conscious life, and
the ability to end conscious life of their
own volition when not being observed. Through
conceptual engineering, a link theoretically
could be forged between these objects and
the Black Moon, allowing observation of them
to stop the obliteration events.
However, despite being a good idea in theory,
Dr. Moto’s efforts were marred with errors
and tragedies. One object wasn’t deadly
enough, simply appearing behind people in
a threatening pose when they weren’t looking.
Another one killed purely through collateral
damage - a giant sculpture of a human head
that immediately attempted escape by barging
through Site-01 - the center for Anti-Black
Moon operations - and killing nineteen people
in the process. Another one of Moto’s objects,
a huge black sphere, simply immediately exploded,
killing twelve people.
And in the most horrific misstep of all, one
of Moto’s objects caused a mass death event
in a nearby hotel, where 142
people were spontaneously
incinerated when the object - a series of
interlocking stalactites and stalagmites - was
left unobserved for 0.2 seconds. Almost all
of Moto’s objects were terminated in the
aftermath, either being too useless or too
dangerous to keep around. The young scientist
felt a deep shame, but forged on.
He made one truly brilliant creation that
satisfied all the criteria: A sculpture, incapable
of moving while being watched, but would snap
the neck of the nearest conscious entity if
left unobserved for even a fraction of a second.
Its relatively minimal killing left it easy
to contain without causing mass deaths, and
despite all the other deaths that had sadly
occurred during the KEY Project, Dr. Moto
believed that the lives saved in the long
run by stopping the Black Moon’s howls would
justify the sacrifice.
The problem is...the KEY Project didn’t
stop anything.
Not long after this, there was the first recorded
double obliteration event in Rome, where a
young tourist couple had both been obliterated
simultaneously. All the deaths in the KEY
Project had been for nothing. The Black Moon
was only getting more powerful.
The shame and the guilt was too much for Dr.
Moto. He left a note in his office, reading,
“We've been looking at nothing. I'm sorry,
Administrator. I've failed you, sir.”
Moto’s corpse was later found in the sculpture’s
temporary containment chamber, his neck snapped.
The KEY Project was, in summary, shut down
and its one surviving creation transported
to Site-19 in late 1993, where it was designated
as SCP-173. Another painful failure for the
Administrator. Back to the drawing board once
more.
Does the Black Moon howl? Not while stars
shine.
millennia stretched on. Almost everyone died,
except The Administrator, thanks to his gift
- or perhaps curse - as the Counterbalance
to the Black Moon. Science marched on, the
SCP Foundation marched on, but all this progress,
all this power, was nothing
against the incomprehensible
influence of SCP-001. The Black Moon was howling
more frequently than ever, all the way up
to the year 3156, when the Foundation launched
the SEEK Project under the support of Project
Oromasdes.
As more and more people were wiped out in
frequent obliteration events, the Administrator
became painfully aware that perhaps the answers
to the Black Moon problem wouldn’t be found
on earth. Using state of the art technology,
with a little help from the anomalous, the
SCP Foundation began work on an autonomous
space-faring vessel that could search the
stars for the key to the Black Moon’s destruction.
It was an awe-inspiring creation, a huge craft
powered by artificial intelligence, with a
universal translator, cryogenic units, and
hundreds of autonomous drones to perform more
targeted searches.
SEEK was waved off into the unforgiving depths
of space. The Administrator could only hope
that it would come back with worthwhile answers.
The first of the three notable planets SEEK
arrived on was one theoretically capable of
supporting human life, except for its brutal
and constant blizzards and snowstorms. When
SEEK’s drones were deployed, they did discover
signs of civilization, based around sentient
spherical creatures, but no signs of actual
life remained. Records and statues found across
the planet seemed to indicate that the Black
Moon was responsible for the destruction of
the planet’s civilization, causing so many
obliteration events that the remaining survivors
went mad from the fear and stress, leading
to mass death in the ensuing chaos.
The next planet was discovered centuries later,
in the year 3499. While this planet could
also theoretically support human life, it
suffered from frequent volcanic eruptions
that rendered much of its surface a flaming
mess. However, there were still the dormant
ruins of a once advanced civilization of conscious
beings. Much like the prior planet, they’d
been driven extinct by Black Moon obliteration
events a century before the SEEK even arrived.
Unlike the last planet, however, it seems
that they accepted their fate, and went gently
into the night. The planet was now overrun
by billions of armored, bat-like creatures
that operated on pure instinct, and thus,
were not considered conscious enough to be
obliterated.
The final planet was reached in 3764, and
was the most fruitful of the three discoveries.
This planet was hyper-advanced, fully urbanized
and covered in sprawling megacities, with
records and technology over a thousand years
ahead of Earth. Before the Black Moon killed
almost all of them, they were a species of
humanoid telepathic fungi, and had developed
an awareness of the Black Moon’s existence
that was on par with that of humanity’s.
They even had their own equivalent of the
SCP Foundation actively
working on countermeasures.
And most amazingly of all, SEEK found one
surviving member of the species on the planet,
cryogenically frozen. The craft was immediately
instructed to collect the survivor and return
home for interrogation. The Administrator
was preparing for what could have been the
most important conversation since he met the
Hermit, all those thousands of years ago.
Does the Black Moon howl? Only when waning.
When the surviving creature, codenamed SAGE,
was returned to Earth, The Administrator was
eager to finally speak with it. Like the rest
of its now-extinct species, SAGE spoke through
powerful telepathic mindwaves, which only
The Administrator - thanks to his Counterbalance
abilities - was able to receive at close range
without being harmed.
Incidentally, it wasn’t long until the very
fact of the Administrator’s nature as a
Counterbalance came up in the mental conversation.
SAGE could tell, just by being in his presence.
They discovered a number of vital truths over
their brief time communicating: That SAGE’s
survival had been pure luck, for starters.
The Black Moon is still very much capable
of obliterating conscious beings in an unconscious
state. The Administrator also learned that
he was merely the latest in an extremely long
line of Counterbalances across time, space,
and species, though everyone but him had waived
the duty, passed it on.
SAGE had one question to ask the Administrator
in turn, “What is SCB?” The Singular Conceptual
Bunker, being worked on and perfected for
thousands of years by now, by the Foundation’s
top scientists and conceptual engineers.
The Administrator replied, “Victory. But
it will take a very, very
long time.” Specifically,
so long that he would see the stars go out
around him, one by one. Shocked, SAGE asked
him what good victory would do him then. Rather
than say it aloud, he replied with a thought.
SAGE paused, and said, “I see. How blasphemous
of you. Hopefully it works.”
After this, the Administrator proceeded to
the Singular Conceptual Bunker and entered
it, leaving instructions for the Foundation
to be run by a newly formed O5 Council in
his indefinite absence. Thousands of years
later, in the year 5011, SAGE spoke one more
time, repeating the words, “Hopefully, hopefully”
before turning solid black, and disappearing.
The Black Moon had claimed one more victim,
but billions more had gone in the interim.
The Administrator had no more answers to give.
At least, no more answers that anyone but
him would understand. He was inside the Singular
Conceptual Bunker now, loaded into a device
known as TOME - an experimental memorial module,
meant to pick up and record all the last messages
of every dying civilization across the universe,
when the time finally came. All he could do
was wait. And wait was exactly what we did.
Does the Black Moon howl?
Yes. Yes it does.
Years pass. Too many to count. It’s a time
after names now, and TOME sits in the very
center, drinking in the end of the universe.
The last of all the human colonies across
the universe were obliterated by the Black
Moon back in the year 7329, so, so, so long
ago, but some of the final messages of fear,
panic, and distress still echoed around the
Administrator’s mind.
"Hello, is there anyone here? We — we require
assistance! There's … it's … it's taking
people every day! We need help! There's barely
anyone left! We need help! Hello? Hello?!"
"Cabal 09:43! We have abandoned the false
flesh! We have abandoned the false flesh!
The shepherds crook broken 'neath my knee!
Cabal 09:43! Cabal 09:43! Forgive us! Forgive
us!"
"We're going to leave this on. It's so dark
outside now. It's blotting out the sun. It's
… I have to go now."
"RESPOND•FIRST•CONVENIENCE
EMERGENCY•SITUATION•DEVELOPING
REQUIRE•ADDITIONAL•RESOURCES."
"My fault. Your fault. Our fault. My fault.
Your fault. Our fault. My fault. Your fault.
Our fault. Rip out my brain now. Rip out my
brain now!"
And a small child, the last on Earth, simply
asking, “Hello?” into an indifferent microphone.
But the Administrator had to wait, as the
Singular Conceptual Bunker became the Solitary
Conceptual Bunker. He was the last conscious
being in the universe, and still, he needed
to wait, as the stars went dark outside. Only
when there was nothing outside but black was
it finally time for the Counterbalance’s
long game to pay off.
There was nothing left of our universe. The
only thing here was the SCB, and the Black
Moon itself. With everything else gone, the
Black Moon only had one conscious being left
to obliterate. It opened the door to the Solitary
Conceptual Bunker, and stepped inside.
This...this doesn’t make sense. How can
the Black Moon, an entity beyond our dimension,
beyond physical form, take a step? Good question.
The same question, incidentally, that was
going through the Black Moon’s mind as it
entered the bunker. It didn’t look at all
how the entity expected: It was like a bar,
a counter with rows of bottles behind it,
a jukebox playing in the corner. A man stood
behind the bar, cleaning glasses.
The Counterbalance. The Administrator.
He said, "Well, there you are! Certainly took
your time. Can I pour you a little something?"
This only served to increase the Black Moon’s
confusion. It had form here, dark smoke compressed
into a vaguely humanoid shape. It could speak?
It could think? None of this made any sense.
The being that’d just wiped out all conscious
life and seen the very death of the universe
was truly and utterly confused.
The Administrator just seemed to be enjoying
himself, preparing for a confrontation hundreds
of billions of years in the making. The Singular
Conceptual Bunker - or perhaps, the Singular
Containment Bunker - was a truly ingenious
creation. A place of pure ideas, where everything
inside was on the same level. Here, there
were no immortals. No Gods. Just ideas, on
the same level playing field. And it was time
for the Black Moon’s idea to come to an
end.
It was a trap, and the entire universe was
the bait.
Without warning, the Administrator pulled
up a shotgun from underneath the table, and
unleashed both barrels into the Black Moon’s
chest.
The creature took the hit and fought back,
dragging the Administrator to the ground,
beating him, strangling him. He could feel
the light fading under the monster’s relentless
assault, until he managed to get his desperate
hands on a glass ashtray. He beat the monster
over the head with it until its grip loosened,
and he was able to slide out.
There, the killer of the universe was on the
ground before him. He grabbed the monster,
held it in place, and beat it to death. He
was gravely injured by the battle, but The
Black Moon was no more. Here, in the Singular
Conceptual Bunker, he had won.
The Administrator, no longer the counterbalance
in the absence of the Black Moon, hobbled
over to the jukebox, producing a single, beautiful
coin from his pocket. He pushed the coin into
the slot, wheezed a pained breath, and said:
“The thing is … this place is only information.
T-There's nothing else out there. Not even
matter. The universe closed its doors a long
time ago. But this place can go from information
back to matter with just the press of a button.
L-Let's see what happens when we introduce
something to nothing…”
For a second, it looks as though he might
fall, but he doesn’t. Instead, he slams
the button on the jukebox and, with a relieved
laugh, says, “Let there be light.”
And there was light.
The fabric of our world is littered with doorways
if you know where to look for them. Tears,
portals, anomalies, all leading to places and
planes beyond human imagining and understanding,
and SCP-2317, otherwise known as A Door to
Another World, certainly fits that description.
Contained and kept at all times under the watch
of armed guards, SCP-2317 appears to be a simple
and unsuspecting wooden door in its frame.
It hardly looks like it requires such extreme
round-the-clock security or needs a strange,
secretive ritual that the Foundation performs,
presumably to keep the door closed. But, of
course, sometimes the most interesting thing
about a closed doorway isn’t where
it leads, it’s what it keeps out.
Even by the Foundation’s already-high standards,
the requirements and regulations for personnel
who are assigned to SCP-2317 seem oddly specific.
Psychological testing is standard practice for to
work for the Foundation, but an additional
hurdle that anyone has to clear before even
getting to glimpse at this unassuming wooden
door is having a score of at least seventy-two
on the Milgram Obedience Examination. It is also
mandatory that personnel assigned to maintaining
it are both unmarried, with no children
or next-of-kin, as well as an unwavering,
unquestioning loyalty to the Foundation,
pure devotion to its code and objectives.
These may seem like strange requirements,
after all, SCP-2317 is just a door…isn’t it?
Perhaps there’s a reason that the Foundation
keeps so much of the information about SCP-2317
buried deep under layers upon layers of security,
with only the Overseer Council privy to the full
details of its strange nature. Knowledge, as they
say, is power - but maybe knowing too much about
whatever is behind that door can prove deadly.
Still, if SCP-2317 is a Door to Another World,
an alternate dimension or parallel reality,
it must be safe enough to visit. After all,
the Foundation has been sending personnel
in there on a regular basis. Daily, in fact.
According to the O5 Council, this
is done as part of a procedure to
maintain Active Containment of…something
lurking beyond that old wooden doorframe.
But what could possibly warrant such
constant maintenance and surveillance?
In accordance with the Foundation’s guidelines,
all staff are required to rotate out of observing
SCP-2317 after every two months and spend the
following third month in full psychological
counselling before they are permitted to return to
the containment unit housing the Door to Another
World. It was after one of these month-long
periods of evaluation that a Foundation guard
was informed that his security clearance
had been raised to Level 3 and that he’d
been selected for the duty of carrying out
220-Calabasas. He knew the name instantly;
this was the title given to the daily containment
procedure that absolutely had to be carried out.
The guard didn’t question these orders, after
all, he’d been selected precisely because of
his loyalty to the Foundation. He did make one
request to his commanding officer, however:
he wanted to know what had happened to the
last guard that had performed the procedure.
“Didn’t make it out of psychological
evaluation,” the officer replied.
Not letting this affect his dedication, the guard
was told to prepare for Procedure 220-Calabasas.
Along with a fellow member of Foundation security
personnel, the guard was instructed to gather
everything on a strange list. The first was
a pre-selected member of Class-D Personnel,
specifically a convicted murderer. Class-D
refers to ‘Disposable Class’ personnel,
expendable individuals recruited by the
Foundation for the sole purpose of testing SCPs.
Class-Ds were usually prison inmates
repurposed for SCP testing, and the
one chosen for 220-Calabasas was no exception,
serving multiple life sentences for murders,
or at least that was what the guard
had been told. A Foundation personnel
member instructed him to refer to the Class-D
solely as the ‘assistant’ from that point on.
Next, the guard collected a live
chicken, an obsidian-edged knife,
a silver aspergillum and aspersorium, to be
filled with 500ccs of Holy Water that had
been blessed by a priest of the Abrahamic faith,
and finally a one-kiloton nuclear device, which,
according to instructions, was to only
be detonated in the unlikely event of a
catastrophic containment failure.
In other words, the last resort.
After following his instructions to the letter and
without question, the guard and his colleague were
briefed. The Foundation personnel member informed
them that he’d be joining and leading them in the
procedure. The staff member also specified that
henceforth he be referred to as the ‘celebrant’
until the completion of 220-Calabasas. The
guard was acutely aware of how specific these
instructions were, but trusted in the Foundation,
knowing that if they wanted this procedure
performed a certain way, then it was in everyones’
best interest to carry out the orders to the
letter. But what the celebrant then went on to
explain, raised far more questions about SCP-2317
and the nature of Procedure 220-Calabasas. The
Class-D joining them, wasn’t actually a Class-D.
The assistant, as they were now referred to,
was in reality another Foundation staff member,
with a Level 4 security clearance, specifically
tailored to SCP-2317. Every member of staff
entering through SCP-2317 and taking an active
role in 220-Calabasas needed to be informed that
this assistant was not to be harmed or treated
as a member of Disposable Class. Fighting back
the nagging question of why the Foundation would
employ this subterfuge, the guard, along with
his fellow security officer, the celebrant and
assistant, prepared for their departure through
the Door to Another World at solar noon, when
the sun was highest over SCP-2317. Solar noon,
chickens and holy water, this all seemed like
an oddly-occult combination for the Foundation.
As they entered the old wooden door, beyond
lay a barren salt plane, stretching out for
kilometers in every direction. This alternate
dimension, according to the briefing,
was designated SCP-2317-Prime. The guard
immediately noticed a ring of seven pillars
directly ahead of the group as they entered, each
of them bearing intricately-detailed engravings
unlike anything from any era of ancient history.
Procedure 220-Calabasas was carried out quickly,
but carefully, the guard watching as the celebrant
and assistant were careful not to miss a step.
First, the celebrant scattered Holy Water
into the center of the pillars with the
aspergillum and aspersorium, looking down
at his feet and keeping a steady pace as he
stepped counter-clockwise around them. The guard
watched intently as the celebrant completed his
circuit around the pillars and turned to the
assistant, anointing his head with Holy Water.
“Seven Seals, Seven Rings, Seven Thrones
for the Scarlet King,” he said aloud.
The assistant, with the obsidian blade in
his hand, took the chicken and dispatched it
in sacrifice, letting its blood mix with the
Holy Water. He then repeated the celebrant’s
circuit in the opposite direction, before
stepping into the center of the stone pillars.
“Blood for the Old Gods, Water for the New King,”
the assistant recited, pouring the remaining mix
of blood and Holy Water over a patch of
salt in the middle of the seven pillars.
Even though he knew it wasn’t his place to
question the Foundation, as the 220-Calabasas
procedure took place, the guard couldn’t
help but wonder what all this was for.
It seemed so…ritualistic, like something
deeply religious or even magical. He’d never
bought into all that occult mumbo-jumbo,
even while working for the Foundation,
but he had learned not to question anything, even
the strangest and most inexplicable of sights.
Little did he know that beneath his feet, was an
ancient and unknowable horror. A beast, chained
and lying in wait. Contained in a chamber directly
underneath the pillars, sat an impossibly-large
creature. Humanoid and obese, its body covered
entirely in scales thicker than armour plating.
Branch-like horns protruded from its jawless
head, pointing up to chains that hung from the
seven pillars above, each one hooked into the
entity’s back. All but one of the chains was
broken, a final, withering shackle keeping the
Devourer of Worlds in its underground prison.
Ever since 1894 BCE, when Erikeshan mystics
imprisoned it, the Devourer has been waiting
patiently for its inevitable freedom. It knows,
as well as the Foundation, that nothing can be
done to prevent the final chain from one day
breaking. Even Procedure 220-Calabasas won’t
keep the creature contained, it’s nothing more
than a smokescreen, an act, designed to create
an illusion of active containment and maintain
Foundation morale until a permanent solution
can be devised to keep SCP-2317 imprisoned.
Of course, if the guard had known this, it would
have also explained the need for a one-kiloton
nuclear device as part of this staged ritual.
Procedure 220-Calabasas has all the components
to trick everyone below the O5 Council,
emulating religious and occult rituals, the
increased level of security surrounding the
procedure and its purpose, and telling staff
that any failure to correctly, and completely,
perform the 220-Calabasas procedure will result
in an XK-Class End of the World Scenario.
All these elements work together to conceal
the truth: that one day, the Devourer will
escape and lay waste to our dimension.
Knowledge is power, and maybe knowing too
much truly is deadly. Perhaps if the guard had
learned any of this, he’d have understood why
his predecessor never made it out of psychological
evaluation. Maybe if he had questioned the purpose
of Procedure 220-Calabasas, he'd have learned the
true nature of SCP-2317, and what that doorway
kept out. But he was loyal to the Foundation,
through and through. As the team finished
performing 220-Calabasas and returned though the
wooden door, the guard took one last glance over
his shoulder at the vast salt plane. The entire
dimension was calm, silent, but not peaceful:
it was patient. The entity had waited centuries
for its time, and now all it would take was the
breaking of the seventh and final chain. One day.
The door was closed behind the guard as he,
the celebrant, the assistant and his fellow
security officer stepped back through,
their work done and, as far as they knew,
preventing catastrophe for another day.
Only the Foundation higher-ups, the Overseer
Council, are aware of the true danger posed
by SCP-2317 and its sole inhabitant. Current
predictions are that at some point within the
next thirty years, the Devourer of Worlds will
be freed. Any and all attempts to repair or
recreate the chains holding it in place have so
far failed. As such, the O5 Council has elected
to continue providing Foundation personnel with
the ignorant hope that Procedure 220-Calabasas
is an effective strategy for containment.
As we’ve said, sometimes the most interesting
thing about a closed door isn’t where it leads,
it’s what it keeps out. In the case of SCP-2317,
the unassuming wooden door holds at bay
an ancient creature of untold power,
that will one day break free and wreak havoc in
our dimension. Nothing the Foundation does can
prevent it, or keep it contained behind the
Door to Another World, and only the Overseer
Council knows that any and all efforts to
do so are futile. With all that in mind,
we can only hope that the doorway of SCP-2317
stays closed, at least for a little while longer.
It was July of 2004, and Bill Murray was enjoying
the peak of an extremely successful career.
Not only had the iconic actor starred in some
of the most beloved comedies of the 20th Century,
including Ghostbusters and Groundhog Day,
he’d voiced the main character
of the recently-released
live action Garfield movie.
It’d been a financial success, but it was
a critical flop.
Not that this bothered Bill – he was happy
with the performance... and the paycheck.
What he wouldn’t be quite as happy about
was the horrifying encounter he was about
to have with SCP – 3166.
On July 8th, Bill was enjoying a cold drink
on the porch of his luxurious Beverly Hills
home.
The sky was beginning to darken as the sun
set in the west.
It was a blissful evening.
His wife, Jennifer, was inside, watching TV.
Nothing seemed particularly out of the ordinary,
until he noticed a quick flash of orange in
the distance.
It was almost too fast to register, this large,
orange shape darting past the corner of his
eye.
For a second, he entertained the thought that
it might have been an escaped tiger, but it
was gone too fast to really tell.
Bill finished his drink and headed inside.
He’d had enough for one night.
The next morning, he got up to read the paper,
and found the Garfield movie getting slaughtered
by the critics.
One review stated “no one can accuse Garfield:
The Movie of infidelity to its source: It
faithfully conveys the banality of Jim Davis's
cartoon” Another called it“a film without
energy and without spirit.”
He put the paper down and ate his breakfast.
A few blows to the ego were worth it for the
paydays that came with big budget family films.
Just then his wife came to him with a strange
question: Were you walking around downstairs
in the middle of the night?
No, he hadn’t, he’d been sleeping like
a baby.
Why did she ask?
“Well…”
Jennifer said.
“I heard some rustling downstairs last night.
It sounded like something big.”
He hadn’t heard anything though and told
her it was probably just her imagination.
He put it out of his mind and continued about
his day.
He decided he would keep his eyes peeled for
that orange blur again though.
Bill didn’t see anything peculiar the rest
of the morning and went to a local café for
lunch.
He ordered a coffee and a cream cheese bagel,
then made a quick trip to the bathroom while
his food was prepared.
When Bill returned to his table though, he
was something strange.
Instead of a bagel, there was a large heaping
of lasagna on the table.
What was going on?
This café didn’t even serve lasagna.
Bill knew something was terribly wrong.
Things only got stranger when Bill came home
to find a small tuft of orange fur snagged
on the frame of his front door.
And it wasn’t synthetic fur like you see
on plush toys or stuffed animals.
No, this was real animal fur.
Maybe someone was just goofing off or trying
to play some weird prank on him, but it didn’t
feel like it.
Deep down, Bill Murray knew that he was in
grave danger.
Whoever, or whatever, was behind this… it
wanted to hurt him.
That night, his worst fears were realized.
Bill’s wife had left town for the week and
he was heading to the kitchen in the middle
of the night for a glass of water, when he
saw something - A huge figure moving up against
the glass door leading to his backyard.
The thing was huge, nearly seven feet tall,
with a bloated, fur-covered, misshapen body
that was pressed up against the door.
Its fur was bright, garish orange – a cartoon
orange.
Strangest of all though was the sound it was
making.
It sounded like it was purring.
Bill backed away from the door and then ran
back to his room to hide.
The whole night, he sat cowering as he heard
scratching against the walls, like something
was trying to get in.
He was terrified and too scared to do anything,
even move.
Finally, as morning broke, the noises seemed
to stop.
Bill had to do something.
He couldn’t let this nightmare go on another
night.
What if things got worse?
What if that thing managed to get inside?
He called the local police and when they arrived,
he explained the incredibly strange situation
as best he could.
He told them he was being stalked by some
kind of huge cat, or at least someone dressed
like a huge cat.
Also there was lasagna involved.
The officers interviewing him could barely
contain their laughter as he told them his
story.
A giant orange cat?
Perhaps, one of them theorized, he’d angered
some kind of obsessive Garfield fan through
his involvement in the live action movie.
After all, the original comic had been running
for years and had been extremely popular.
Who knows what kind of nut jobs were obsessed
with seeing only a faithful adaptation of
the source material?
As the officers departed, Bill was confident
that they weren’t taking him seriously.
He couldn’t rely on any of them for protection.
Thankfully, from a multi-decade movie career,
he had plenty of disposable income, and decided
to hire a private security team to protect
him while he looked into this mystery.
He had two trained bodyguards positioned around
his home at all times for the next month.
They were armed, and given the cryptic orders
to fire on anything orange.
Meanwhile, Bill began to fall down a Garfield
rabbit hole.
He felt strangely compelled to research all
the Garfield media he could find, as though
the answer to his terrifying situation was
somehow hidden between the lines.
Bill explored the entire backlog of thousands
of comic strips.
He read the books and interviews with Jim
Davis.
He watched the cartoons and straight-to-DVD
animated movies.
Ironically for a guy who’d recently portrayed
the lasagna-loving orange cat, Bill had never
felt quite so immersed in the character before.
He found a strange pathos in the routine of
Garfield and his friends.One particular comic
really piqued his interest, though.
Originally published in October of 1989, the
comic began with Garfield being woken up by
a strange chill, an almost eerie sensation.
The character observed aloud that he didn’t
feel like he was in his own home.
He explored his little home further, trying
to find his owner Jon or his housemate and
sometimes nemesis, Odie, but found nothing.
As Garfield remarked on feeling alone, a purple
speech box delivered the sinister message:
“You have no idea how alone you are, Garfield.”
He then finds that his home looks like it’s
been abandoned for years.
The “For Sale” sign outside is practically
ancient.
Garfield slowly comes to a horrifying revelation:
Everyone really is gone, and his adventures
and friends now exist only in his imagination.
He’s trapped in a prison of his own creation,
trying to stave off his endless loneliness,
in denial about the reality of his situation.
The comic ended with a quote directly from
Jim Davis himself, saying “An imagination
is a powerful tool.
It can tint memories of
the past, shade perceptions
of the present, or paint a future so vivid
that it can entice... or terrify, all depending
upon how we conduct ourselves today...”
As he read those words, Bill Murray felt a
chill down his spine.
Why had he wanted to get involved in the Garfield
movie in the first place?
What had he gotten himself into?
Before he could slip any deeper into his own
mind, Bill heard a faint,
choked scream downstairs.
He felt his breath catch in his throat.
He was terrified but he needed to see what
was happening.
He carefully and quietly began to creep down
the stairs.
At the bottom, he poked his head around a
corner, and that’s when he saw a member
of his security detail lying dead on the floor.
His face was blue from asphyxiation, his mouth
was stuffed with lasagna.
It looked like he had been force-fed to death.
Bill wanted to scream but he couldn’t, or
maybe knew he shouldn’t.
Just then he heard a soft, meaty thumping
noise coming from the nearby living room.
He didn’t know why, but he felt compelled
to approach as if by forces beyond his control.
He made his way to the living room, and when
he got there, he saw where the noise was coming
from.
Bill’s jaw dropped in pure horror.
There was the other member of his security
detail, lying limp and lifeless under a giant
orange figure.
It was a grotesquely huge creature, wearing
what looked to be a kind of crude Garfield
outfit made of sewn-together cat pelts.
It stank of pasta and rotten meat.
In its giant paw, it held a golden trophy,
which it was using to pound the security guard’s
head into mush while making quiet, cat-like
purring noises.
The creature suddenly stopped and looked up,
locking eyes with Bill.
The fear of death came over him.
He froze, as the giant, freakish Garfield
stepped over Donny’s corpse, and began to
come towards him.
Bill turned and ran, but Garfield was gaining
on him.
Before he could make it to the front door,
the creature knocked him over.
He was laid out on the ground, looking up
at it, as it reached into its own body cavity
and began to pull out handfuls of lasagna.
He was just about to shove a wad of the horrible
decaying pasta into Bill’s mouth, when suddenly,
a DING was heard and the creature stopped.
It looked up, as if sniffing the air, and
then suddenly turned and lumbered towards
the kitchen.
Bill watched as the Garfield monster entered
the kitchen where, somehow, there was a steaming
hot fresh lasagna sitting in the open oven.
The creature had sensed the presence of external
lasagna, and felt the compulsion to integrate
it into its body, grabbing fistfulls and shoving
it into itself.
Just then, a group of highly
trained SCP Foundation
personnel burst into the room and subdued
the creature.
It had been an ambush.
The Foundation had been tipped off to the
presence of the creature by monitoring the
local police department dispatches, and the
report of a seven foot tall comic book cat
terrorizing a Hollywood actor was definitely
worth looking into.
The monster that had almost taken Bill Murray’s
life was SCP – 3166, a deadly pataphysical
being that tends to manifest around people
somehow involved in the Garfield intellectual
property.
It appears whenever the public perception
of Garfield falls out of favor, and because
Bill had starred in the critically-panned
Garfield movie, he was currently at the very
top of SCP – 3166’s hit list.
Thankfully, he managed to survive his terrifying
ordeal, and was administered amnestics by
Foundation personnel so he could return to
his normal life.
This frightening and mysterious creature has
been around since 1989, appearing after the
publication of the haunting Garfield comic
that Bill had read that very night.
It appeared in the office of United Media,
who were the publishers of the Garfield comic
strip at the time, and began wreaking havoc.
Since then, the creature’s manifestation
has been a constant threat whenever Garfield
loses its popularity or audience.
As a result, the Foundation has spent years
as the funding source behind all Garfield
media, and even planting hypnotic memetics
into the comic strips to ensure that there
is always a loyal fanbase.
The fur is indeed real, organic cat fur, albeit
an unnaturally orange color, and instead of
organs, the creature is filled with lasagna.
Worst of all though, is that testing has revealed
that the meat in the lasagna is genetically
identical to the flesh of Garfield’s creator,
Jim Davis.
How did this thing come into existence?
Perhaps it was Jim’s sheer force of imagination
that dragged it into being.
As he himself said, “An imagination is a
powerful tool.”
All in all, it’s lucky that Bill Murray
was able to survive his encounter, and return
to his normal life – well, as normal as
life can be for Bill Murray.
And if you see Bill Murray, don’t bother
asking him about SCP – 3166.
The amnestics were quite effective, and just
as he’s fond of saying himself, no one will
ever believe you.
If there’s anything that recent years have sadly
taught us, it’s that diseases are an insidious
and formidable enemy that can take you by
surprise. Whether it’s bacterial, a virus,
a fungal infection, or even an unfortunate genetic
mutation like cancer, Alzheimer’s, or Multiple
Sclerosis, sometimes dealing with a dangerous
pathogen could leave you praying for a run-in with
SCP-682 after all, at least getting devoured
by a giant, evil reptile is a quick death.
But take a page out of the SCP
Foundation’s book: Sometimes,
the best response to an imminent threat is
containment and research. One of the first
rules of combat is to know your enemy.
It may seem like a tall order to have
to write the book on dangerous diseases, but
thankfully, that book has already been written:
it’s SCP-1025 The Encyclopedia of Common Diseases.
This handy, reader-friendly volume will tell
you everything you need to know about all the
common maladies you may find yourself facing,
and a whole lot more. From the sniffles to lung
cancer, from a cold sore to necrotizing fasciitis.
You may be thinking, “Why would I need some
dusty old book to tell me about diseases? I
can always just go to WebMD.” But you don’t want
that. You know what the internet is like: They’ll
just tell you you’re sick, and you don’t want
them putting silly ideas in your head like that.
How about you open up to a random page and we’ll
take a look. There, see? The Common Cold. Classic.
Let’s see the description: “The Common Cold is a
virus that affects the upper respiratory tract.
Its duration is typically a maximum of two weeks,
and its primary symptoms include headaches, muscle
aches, a cough, a runny nose, raised temperature,
pressure in the ears or face, and a loss of taste
or smell.” See? Simple, straightforward,
and objective. Exactly what you need.
Did you just cough? That’s strange. Hmm, and come
to think of it, your nose is looking a little red.
Do you need a tissue? Or perhaps a throat lozenge?
Your voice seems a little hoarse. Perhaps you
ought to take a break and lay down. You really
don’t look so good. Seems like the common cold
to us. Thankfully, you shouldn’t have to
worry about it for more than two weeks. Oh,
and that reminds me: There is a certain anomalous
effect to the Encyclopedia of Common Diseases.
Whenever you read about a pathogen in the
Encyclopedia of Common Diseases, you catch it,
manifesting even its most severe symptoms in
an extremely brief period of time. Of course,
this isn’t that much of a problem if
you just read the article about having
a sore throat or a stomach bug, but what
if you read the page for Ebola? Suddenly,
you’re half-dead and bleeding from the
eyes. Or the Bubonic Plague? Or a disease
that humanity has never even faced before?
And what if, worst of all, the people who
catch the diseases from this book continue to
be contagious to others? It could be the basis
for a world-destroying biological weapon and at
the very least, a bonafide Keter-Class anomaly.
When the SCP Foundation got their hands on
this little hardcover anomalous nightmare,
the researchers handling this thing
realized it needed to be kept under
lock and key. A new provisional site was
created just to contain and research it
without the risk of its anomalous effects
starting an unstoppable global pandemic.
The base was an isolated underground
bunker, containing an even more
high-security containment unit to store the
book itself: A vault surrounded by at least
ten armed guards at any given time, rotated
twice weekly and checked for any infectious
agents. There was even a powerful thermite bomb
stored beneath the vault, set to go off and
annihilate the entire chamber if the plausible
risk of a containment breach was detected.
It may seem insane to put in this many security
fail-safes for a simple anomalous book, but the
SCP Foundation has dealt with dangerous books
before. Take SCP-140, also known as an Incomplete
Chronicle. This dangerous historical volume
chronicles the living history of the Daevites,
an extinct culture of sadistic sorcerers
closely tied to the mythos of the Scarlet
King. Whenever ink or blood is brought into the
presence of this book, it absorbs the material,
expanding the Daevite’s history and bringing their
terrifying rule ever closer to the modern day.
Or take SCP-3512, “The More You Know: A Pick-Up
Artist’s Bible”, a deadly instruction manual made
by a mind-controlling group of interest known
as the Fifthists. This book gave its sinister
practitioners the tools to control the minds of
their potential romantic partners, often leading
to their deaths. While it may not be quite as
apocalyptic as SCP-1025 or SCP-140, the fact
that there are so many in circulation still makes
it a dangerous threat. Point is, a book can be a
dangerous thing, especially if its pages have the
potential to unlock deadly diseases like SCP-1025.
As you can expect with an infectious Keter-Class
anomaly of this magnitude, procedures around this
one were rigorous. The site staff was a skeleton
crew, observing strict quarantine procedures to
prevent any potential infection from leaking out
into the wider world. Research into the history
of the book was inconclusive, despite a bevy of
Foundation resources being poured into finding
any worthwhile leads on the author or publisher
of the book. Nothing. It was an absolute mystery
who or what had put this XK-Class End of the World
Scenario waiting to happen here on earth. But now,
it was the job of these intrepid researchers to
discover the full extent of its potential dangers.
27 D-Class subjects were allocated
to the base for testing. By the time
the process was over, none of these
unlucky prisoners would remain alive.
The tests started much like this video: The
Researchers forced a D-Class to read the
section on the Common Cold. Within two hours,
the subject began coughing. Upon being asked,
they also reported feeling physically achey,
though they attributed the ache to sleeping on
an uncomfortable D-Class cot every night.
The researchers were concerned already:
The incubation period for the common cold -
meaning the period a person is infected before
showing active symptoms - can be as long
as three days. Two hours is unprecedented.
Next, a D-Class was told to read the section on
Chicken Pox, a common childhood malady that can be
considerably more dangerous in adulthood. Within
an hour of being exposed, the D-Class repeatedly
scratched no less than five points on her body
repeatedly. While she claimed this was because
of the itchy D-Class jumpsuits, it was too eerily
close to a symptom of Chicken Pox to be ignored.
The medical history of this D-Class also showed
that she’d suffered Chicken Pox in childhood,
suggesting that SCP-1025 infections have
the power to override previous immunities.
Next, things got a little more serious:
They tested the section on lung cancer
on a D-Class with no family history
of lung conditions. Not long after,
the researchers noted that the D-Class coughed
an unusual number of times. Not only that, they
picked up irregularities in the D-Class’ breathing
that appeared to be characteristic of lung cancer.
While the D-Class did not report any feelings
of chest pain or discomfort, the researchers
had him terminated and dissected. No tumors were
found. A researcher noted that they didn’t wait
long enough for proper tumor manifestation -
They knew they heard that D-Class coughing.
The researchers were so concerned
by the results of the previous test,
they repeated it exactly with another D-Class,
who they then observed over a period of seven
days to track tumor manifestation. Researchers
made a note of an unusual amount of coughing
and wheezing from the subject over this period
of time. The D-Class was then terminated and
dissected - But surprise, surprise, no tumors.
Researchers began to consider the frightening
possibility that signs of SCP-1025-induced
illness disappear after the victims die,
meaning that a pandemic started by SCP-1025 would
be impossible to properly track and respond to.
Things were only getting scarier and
scarier for the SCP-1025 researchers,
sequestered away in that
isolated Foundation bunker.
Researchers continued to delve further into the
lung cancer rabbit hole: This time, however,
they didn’t wait for the subject to die
before looking at their insides. They
instead performed a vivisection on the
subject, only to find that despite the
victim still being alive and displaying
some of the key symptoms of lung cancer,
there were no tumors. What could this mean?
These diseases weren’t behaving like any of their
non-anomalous counterparts. What other differences
could we be dealing with here? Infectious lung
cancer? And what if there are more books out
there, like time bombs, just waiting to go off?
The tests continued, getting more isolated
and more intense. In the end, the SCP-1025
site was staffed by only three researchers and
two agents acting as guards. D-Classes were sent
in one by one to minimize ration requirements.
It seemed they could have been dealing with one
of the most dangerous anomalies of all time
- even working with it could be a trigger
for the apocalypse, if the proper containment
and quarantine procedures weren’t observed.
Things got so out of hand that a D-Class
without an appendix was told to read the
section on Appendicitis, and researchers
still observed him exhibiting symptoms of
the condition. He was vivisected, and while the
appendix was still not present, the organs in
the area where the appendix would have been seemed
redder than usual. Where would this nightmare end?
Well, it would actually end much sooner than
anyone involved would anticipate. Despite never
even reading SCP-1025 himself, a researcher
developed a strange persistent cough and was
quarantined in a containment chamber by his
concerned colleagues. On the seventh day of
his confinement, he seemed to be slightly taller
than before - a symptom of SCP-016, a deadly,
anomalous blood-borne pathogen that multiplies
wildly and rewrites the genetic structure of
its host if placed into a high-stress situation.
This led to a number of terrifying revelations:
Not only did the book have the potential
to inflict a number of anomalous diseases,
but it could also potentially do so by pure
proximity, even if you don’t actually read it.
What other anomalous diseases could be
on the table now? What about SCP-008,
a terrifying prion with both 100% virality and
100% lethality? Or SCP-742, a retrovirus that
slowly but surely transforms its victims
into cannibalistic monsters? Or even the
horrifying SCP-217, the disease that slowly
converts your entire body into a mechanical
nightmare? There would be no limit to
the horrors SCP-1025 could unleash on
the world if ever it got out. They needed
to keep this thing locked up at any cost.
That’s when the infected researcher
escaped, and all hell broke loose.
The isolated facility went dark for 72 hours.
After not being able to get into contact with
any other Foundation bases during that time,
a recovery team was sent to investigate the
mystery. One agent and one researcher
were found in the observation booth,
wearing biological containment suits. Another
agent was found crawling through the air ducts
with his handgun drawn, a crazed look in his
eye. An additional researcher had locked himself
in the barracks with a homemade flamethrower,
paranoid about infection. And the final agent
was found dead in a storage locker with some
empty bottles and ration packages, after having
given the door an airtight seal to prevent
infection - then dying of suffocation inside.
The O5 Council shuttered the entire investigation.
SCP-1025 was downgraded from Keter to Safe Class,
then placed in a storage locker. The
whole thing was considered a wash. We
know what you’re probably wondering: Why!?
If this anomaly was so incredibly dangerous,
why on earth would the O5 Council and the rest
of the Foundation be dealing with it so casually?
Well, that’s simple: The initial batch of
researchers had grievously misjudged the actual
anomalous effect of SCP-1025. It doesn’t give
diseases to those who read its text - instead,
it induces a form of “hypochondria by proxy”
to those around the reader. In other words,
while SCP-1025 has no effect on the reader, it
makes everyone around them merely believe that
they’ve come down with a terrible illness. The
few members of staff in that isolated site had
been killing and dissecting D-Classes for no
reason. In effect, they’d all effectively gone
mad due to the anomalous effects of SCP-1025 and
the paranoia induced by pressure and isolation.
Much like your average hypochondriac,
they’d warped the data to fit the worst
possible outcome rather than the more mundane
and likely. As an old medical expression goes,
“When you see hoofprints, think
horses, not zebras.” The entire
thing had been a terrifying waste
of time, money, and human life.
So perhaps, in the end, the Encyclopedia
of Common Diseases is a lot more like WebMD
than we thought. It’s not nearly as useful as
getting a consultation with an actual doctor,
and of course, it’s liable to put some
very strange ideas in your head...
There is something so captivating about ice.
It can be beautiful, a shimmering cast of
frost over a meadow or twinkling icicles on
a cottage roof.
It can also be deadly: A slick of slippery
glass on a dark road, or that same icicle
from before, knocked loose and careening toward
your head like a falling dagger.
It can be a sleet storm or a mighty glacier
with secrets buried beneath its core.
In a remote part of Alaska, the SCP Foundation
discovered a particularly unusual kind of
ice, with a vivid red hue and some incredibly
deadly potential.
The Foundation investigated reports in a remote
area on the Alaskan coastline after a tribe
of local natives came across the mangled bodies
of shipwrecked hunters in the area, encased
in a block of strange red ice.
Mobile Task Force Beta-7, also known as The
Haz-Matters, was sent in to the site to determine
what exactly had occurred and take samples
of any anomalous materials to be brought back
to the nearest Foundation research site.
Agent Bryce made the initial visual inspection
of the site and spotted three middle-aged
male bodies.
Further examination determined that one of
the bodies, referred to as Subject Zero, was
the original point of contamination for whatever
comprised the red ice and caused the men’s
deaths.
It has been posited by the investigative team
that the other men were infected when they
attempted to help Subject Zero reach their
boat.
Sadly, kindness can sometimes be a killer
like that.
While sweeping the perimeter, Agent Hewes
spotted human footprints leading to the Northeast.
A three-man team consisting of Agents Hewes,
Whitmore, and Cassidy was permitted to follow
those tracks and determine if any survivors,
or something worse, had escaped the site.
Exploration Log A009 1 allows us to determine
what happened next, and what the three agents
found.
Hewes and his team followed the footprints
to the entrance of a cave, with the tracks
appearing to lead inside.
The entrance of the cave was covered with
an almost solid sheet of ice, save for a crack
in the ice about one meter tall.
Beyond this wall, Agent Whitmore spotted the
body of a young man, frozen solid in the midst
of crawling away from something, covered in
crystals of red ice.
With him was a frozen spear gun that appeared
to have been fired just before the young man’s
death.
They could not touch the body to perform a
full investigation, but the way in which he
was gripping his chest indicated he might
have been fatally stabbed there.
As the agents moved further into the cave,
they discovered a chamber about 5 or 6 meters
in diameter, filled with red ice with a pool
in the middle.
The pool was three meters wide and of an unknown
depth.
As they pushed further, the agents came across
a polar bear.
Startled, they fired once at it, before realizing
it was already dead.
Its fur was dotted with crystals of red ice,
creeping its way across the bear’s body.
Beyond the polar bear, the agents spotted
dozens of bodies, all dead animals.
There were seals, a snow fox, and finally…a
giant spider, with a leg span of over a meter.
At first, the spider appeared to be frozen
like the other creatures, but upon further
investigation, it appeared to be made of red
ice.
Agent Cassidy recognized the spider as SCP-3023
but was told it was impossible.
When she pressed for further answers, she
was told to ignore it and continue the sweep.
Agent Whitmore checked the collection of bodies
in the chamber, looking for any humans among
them.
Meanwhile, Hewes spotted a spear sticking
out of the enormous spider, indicating a struggle
that took place before it and the young man
at the cave’s entrance froze.
Hewes was interrupted in his task as Agent
Cassidy called out from deeper in the cave,
saying: “I think I know where the spider
came from.”
When Hewes followed the sound of her voice,
he found something troubling.
An aperture, about a meter in diameter, absolutely
covered in red ice.
It looked like a tunnel, with no ice at all
past its entrance, with a dim light coming
from somewhere deep inside.
He lost sight of Agent Cassidy and realized
she must have gone inside of it.
Upon further observation, Hewes determined
that the walls and the floor of the tunnel
were wet, with a red puddle about a meter
in.
Hewes and Whitmore called to Cassidy, attempting
to lead her back out of the tunnel, but received
no response.
Hewes attempted to go in and retrieve her,
but Control forbade him from going any further.
After a conversation with Control that has
been stricken from the official file, Hewes
relented and agreed to withdraw his remaining
team and exit the site.
Hewes and Whitmore left the cave without further
incident and returned to Foundation headquarters.
In spite of a D-Class recovery team being
sent into the cave to search for her, Agent
Cassidy’s body was never found.
The cave was blocked off from the public,
in order to avoid further civilian contact
with the red ice and red water inside.
Though the origin of the red ice in Alaska
is not known for sure, this cave, and the
pool deep within it, are thought to be the
source of this particular infestation.
The official cause of death listed on record
for the bodies found in Alaska was internal
bleeding, but what really happened to them
was something much, much worse.
These men had transformed and frozen from
the inside out, their blood turning to ice
and their cells going solid one at a time.
The low ambient temperatures in the area are
thought to have slowed the freezing process
down.
You heard that right, the cold kept them from
freezing faster, as counterintuitive as it
sounds.
This prolonged their deaths and kept them
conscious up until the very end.
Even as their bodies were freezing solid,
their very cells turning against them, they
were awake and aware of it all.
These unfortunate men came into contact with
and lost their lives to a substance known
as SCP-009.
SCP-009 in its liquid form, maintained at
temperatures between -100 and 0 degrees Celsius,
resembles ordinary distilled water aside from
its bright red color.
It behaves opposite of water, reaching a frozen
solid state at higher temperatures, and vaporizing
into a steam-like gas at temperatures below
-100 degrees.
An attempt to examine SCP-009’s atomic structure
was unable to achieve conclusive results.
The substance looks as if it is made up of
normal water molecules, though obviously,
it is much more than simple water.
SCP-009 appears relatively harmless at first
glance, but its real dangerous potential lies
in its ability to contaminate water-based
solutions, transferring its properties to
them.
A contaminated liquid begins to exhibit the
same unusual behavior as SCP-009, freezing
at temperatures above 0 degrees and vaporizing
at temperatures below -100.
It has been shown to effectively contaminate
ice, steam, tea, fruit juice, seawater, and
blood, in a process taking between three minutes
and several hours.
These concerning properties raised questions
about what SCP-009, and liquids contaminated
by it, might do if they make contact with
a human body.
Several D-Class Personnel were used as test
subjects, exposed to SCP-009 in a controlled
environment and observed from a safe distance.
When first exposed to SCP-009, the test subjects
reported nothing unusual except a slight sensation
of warming on the surface of their skin.
Then, frost began to form across the surface
of the exposed area as the subject’s body
heat raised the substance’s temperature.
This process took between a minute and a few
hours, during which ice crystals began to
form along the top layer of the skin.
This stage is known as “Surface Conversion.”
In the next stage, “Deep Tissue Conversion,”
the continued increase in SCP-009’s temperature
causes a ripple effect of reactions through
the subject’s body, ice crystals forming
in the cells and throughout the blood.
The subject remained alive and conscious during
this stage.
Details about the fourth stage of the process
have been expunged from the official record,
but it is safe to say that something horrible
happened.
After several of these experiments were conducted,
testing on living D-class subjects was officially
discontinued.
There was a possibility of experimentation
on SCP-009 regarding its potential application
to cold fusion, but this was also eventually
discontinued following a disastrous accident
at an unnamed Foundation test site.
The site was completely destroyed, and pieces
of the lead Agent conducting the cold fusion
research have still not been recovered.
For now, SCP-009 is kept under strict containment
and only tested under particular, highly regulated
circumstances.
SCP-009 is kept in a sealed storage tank of
heat-resistant alloy.
It is not to be exposed to any temperatures
higher than zero degrees Celsius unless there
is official, Foundation-sanctioned testing
being done.
No water-based liquids are allowed within
30 meters of the containment area.
The storage tank is outfitted with temperature
sensors that are to be monitored at all times
in order to prevent the temperature within
from rising and is kept cold by three different
cooling units.
If the sensors or cooling units malfunction
for any reason, they must be fixed immediately
to prevent disaster.
When testing is done on SCP-009, the containment
area is kept in a vacuum and the personnel
working with it must wear protective gear.
After testing, all involved personnel must
quarantine for at least 12 hours.
Any living organisms contaminated by SCP-009
must be terminated promptly.
While the exact origins of SCP-009 are unclear,
it clearly does not follow the laws of nature
as we understand them.
A Foundation expert in Xenospatial Physics
suggested that SCP-009 may have come from
a universe with alternate laws of physics,
explaining its reversal of the ordinary conditions
for states of matter.
During an instance of SCP-507 - The reluctant
dimension hopper - shifting into an alternate
universe, an instance of SCP-009 was unexpectedly
observed that may help confirm that theory.
In the test area where SCP-507 appeared, red
snow fell for about 27 minutes.
Grass touched by this red snow began to react
and freeze over within a few minutes.
The other plant life touched by the snow turned
bright red and expanded to a larger size.
It also began to sprout bright blue tentacles
covered with red mucilage.
Upon closer examination, the mucilage turned
out to be comprised of small amounts of SCP-009.
This raised additional questions, for instance:
how are these plants able to survive constant
exposure to SCP-009?
This matter is currently under investigation,
but the prevailing theory is that this plant
is an example of plant life from SCP-009’s
native universe.
Whatever it is, and wherever it comes from,
it should not be allowed to come into contact
with earth-based organic life forms.
Well, not unless being horrifically frozen
to death by your own body feels like an appealing
experience to you.
The coastline where SCP-009 was initially
discovered, and its first victims on record
were found, was located very close to the
ocean.
Thankfully, the exact area of contamination
was dry and cold enough to keep the red ice
from spreading, but if it had been even a
few meters closer to the water it could have
spread into the North Pacific Ocean.
With contamination of that scale, it could
have very easily infected thousands of people,
perhaps spreading into other bodies of water
and triggering a global extinction event.
Because of this threat, several members of
the SCP Foundation proposed that SCP-009 be
upgraded to Keter class in order to reflect
its danger to humanity.
However, this request was denied due to the
currently effective containment measures in
place.
The red ice is unable to spread to new hosts,
infecting the water supply and turning all
living things into frozen husks.
For now.
Let’s just hope we don’t see any red snowstorms
any time soon.
There is something maddening about a repetitive,
consistent sound, don’t you agree?
The narrator of Edgar Allen Poe’s The Tell-Tale
Heart is driven mad by the nonstop beating
of a heart coming from beneath his floorboards.
But even something less
horrible than a disembodied
heartbeat can fray a person’s nerves.
Superficially less horrible, anyway.
Something as simple as, say, the relentless
ticking of a clock.
After all, what could be more frightening
than a reminder of the sands of time passing
through our fingers?
Of the finite steps on life’s long and winding
road?
We have the answer to that question: The scariest
thing of all is the monster waiting on the
other side of the road, twisted and hungry.
The thing that strikes when the ticking eventually
stops.
When time is up.
Tick.
Tock.
Many years ago, a clockmaker in the German
town of Freiburg was renowned for his ability
to produce exquisite personalized clocks for
his clientele all across the town, the country,
and even beyond.
His unparalleled constructions made him the
only man to reach out to when it came to getting
your hands on a beautiful, ornate timepiece
that would ease the anxieties of the passing
hours.
He ate, slept, and breathed clocks.
It was his life.
His calling.
As such, the clockmaker had grown accustomed
to the sound of ticking.
He heard it in the morning when he awoke to
the cry of his cuckoo clock, he listened to
it all day in his workshop as he repaired
and constructed clocks of all shapes and sizes,
and it was the sound that lulled him to sleep
at night after each long, hard day.
It gave life a pleasant rhythm.
One day, however, he noticed a particularly
loud, repetitive sound had permeated his home.
It was rhythmic, like the ticking of his clocks,
but harsher somehow.
It did not gently tick, but rather cracked,
like the way his knees popped when a harsh
winter was coming.
Something in it made his stomach ache with
dread.
He began taking apart every clock in his workshop,
looking for the source of the sound, but still,
it persisted.
He sat there at his desk, surrounded by gears
and pieces of wood, glass, and metal, and
still, the sound pounded against his eardrums.
Tick.
Tock.
The clockmaker was stumped by the mysterious
ticking noise.
It felt too real, too vivid, to be some kind
of hallucination.
He would have bet every clock he ever made
that the noise was coming from outside of
his head.
He was a man so astute in his clock-making
abilities that he could tell his own creations
apart in the dark from the mere timbre of
their ticking, but here, he was in the presence
of an alien force.
This frightening, almost predatory sound that
lingered in his periphery, always somewhere
but not confined to any fixed point.
He was reminded, vaguely, of Peter Pan.
Of the crocodile that’d eaten Captain Hook’s
hand and alarm clock, which survived and continued
ticking in the literal belly of the beast.
Hook, a vicious pirate captain, would become
a gibbering wreck when the ticking sound got
closer.
Did he fear the predator whom the ticking
foretold or the passage of time that pushed
him further into the reaper’s fold in the
otherwise immortal plane of Neverland?
Tick.
Tock.
The clockmaker’s search continued.
He turned his workplace upside down and inside
out in pursuit of the seemingly sourceless
ticking.
He checked in every hiding place, every closet,
cupboard, cubby hole, and cabinet.
Nothing.
He moved the furniture, tied up the curtains,
rolled up all the carpets.
Nothing.
In his desperation, he took a claw hammer
from his toolbox and began prying the rusty
nails from the ground, before peeling up the
floorboards and checking
the dusty, spider-infested
spaces underneath.
Perhaps some mechanism had fallen down there,
or had always been there, just ticking away.
There had to be something down there.
But no.
Only dirt, insects, and shadows.
Maybe he was going mad.
Maybe it was tinnitus, or the indelible impression
that hearing years upon years of ticking had
left in his mind, the way an image is burned
into a plasma screen if it’s left there
for too long.
Maybe it was some shadowy government agency
trying to drive him mad with the use of some
new sound-based torture device.
Aural terrorism.
Selective auditory subliminal mind control.
Havana Syndrome.
The fizzling edges of sanity
egged on by invisible,
long-range CIA telesound beams.
There had to be some kind of explanation.
But whatever the case, the sound persisted.
Tick, Tock, Tick, Tock…
He couldn’t stay there, in the dismembered
ruins of his prestigious clockmaking shop,
any longer.
He was clearly under a lot of stress here.
Not healthy.
Not good for the mind.
He decided to close the shop for a few days
and go visit his daughter and her family.
Some time with his beloved relatives would
soothe his frayed nerves.
So he packed his bag and made the trip, hoping
that leaving work behind for a few days would
also loosen up his mind.
But the entire drive to his daughter’s house,
he could have sworn he heard the sound still,
keeping perfect time as it cracked again and
again.
He shook his head, scolding himself for imagining
things.
There was nothing in the car that could be
making that noise.
He’d focused on it too much, surely, that’s
why he was obsessing over it now.
All of this had a rational explanation; he’d
simply thought himself into a corner on this
one.
Wouldn’t that explain all of this?
All just a trick in the mind of an overworked
clockmaker sorely in need of a good sabbatical
in the country.
This wouldn’t be forever.
Tick, Tock, Tick, Tock…
The clockmaker’s daughter greeted him at
the door with a warm embrace and a hearty
meal, and for a little while, he relaxed.
The sound of good company and laughter drowned
out the infernal ticking.
He began to entertain the notion that, perhaps,
the ticking had been a good thing.
It’d been a long time since he’d seen
his daughter, and that ticking, as frightening
as it had been, was also the only thing that
pushed him away from the workshop for a while.
He was somewhat grateful for a good excuse
to take time off.
Perhaps that was what all this was about.
A reminder to take it easy.
After a weekend off, he’d be right as rain,
surely?
But that night, as he tried to fall asleep,
the sound was there again.
Taunting him.
Keeping his eyes open wide and his heart rate
climbing.
Was it the dark of the room magnifying his
hearing, intensifying that awful ticking,
or was it louder and closer than ever before?
It felt as though an invisible clock, like
so many he’d made before, was hanging over
him.
But what was holding it?
That awful, awful sound.
Like the bubbles popping in the synovial fluids
of a person’s aged and crumbling joints.
Too organic.
Too fleshy.
And it just kept getting louder and closer,
louder and closer, louder and closer…
Tick…..Tock….Tick…Tock..Tick, TOCK,
TICK, TOCK, TICK, TOCK…
Until suddenly…it went silent.
He breathed a sigh of relief and closed his
eyes.
The clockmaker’s daughter woke to the sound
of her father’s piercing, guttural screams.
She ran to his room to find the bed sheets
soaked with blood, the bedroom window shattered,
and her father gone without a trace.
She went to the police the next day, but they
could do nothing for her.
Her father had not been the victim of an ordinary
murderer or thief, but something outside the
realm of understanding.
It was something ancient, something monstrous,
something…anomalous.
Though the police could do nothing, another
organization was secretly on the case: The
SCP Foundation.
After the clockmaker’s disappearance, operatives
searched the area and discovered the culprit,
which they captured and designated SCP-4975.
SCP-4975 is a humanoid entity with bird-like
features, the most notable of which is a sharp,
pointed beak.
Its body is long and thin, with bony limbs
with tapered points, with no discernible digits
of any kind.
Its body, including its beak, is covered with
a thick, hard layer of skin.
The entity’s most notable feature is not
its appearance, however, but in its skeleton,
particularly its spine.
The cervical vertebrae of the creature are
not interconnected, and are capable of independent
movement.
They rotate, one vertebra at a time, from
back to front in order, all the way up to
the entity’s head, in a particular rhythm.
This produces the clicking, or cracking sound
that is so terribly familiar to its intended
victims.
It repeats the motion constantly, over and
over again, only stopping when it is preparing
to attack its chosen prey.
SCP-4975 does not kill impulsively, simply
selecting a convenient victim.
Instead, it stalks its prey for months at
a time, sometimes even a year, following them
in darkness, hiding just out of sight.
The only sign of its presence is that sound,
the clicking, cracking, tick tock, tick tock
of its bones as it bides its time, knowing
that it can wait as long as it needs or wants
to before it strikes.
When it is ready to feast, it will beat and
tear at the victim’s body with the tapered
points of its limbs, shredding the flesh and
pecking at it much like a vulture rips at
a fresh carcass.
Then, it can savor its meal, using the body
as food for about three months before it needs
to hunt again.
Though its exact age is unknown, it is theorized
that the creature is hundreds, if not thousands,
of years old.
Written evidence of its existence has been
traced back as far as the 1500s.
There are mentions of a creature resembling
SCP-4975 throughout German folklore, appearing
in carvings, paintings, folk tales, and nursery
rhymes.
One such nursery rhyme was discovered and
translated by the Foundation during the research
process.
Though its rhyme scheme was lost when it was
translated to English, the eerie feeling it
evokes was not.
The rhyme goes:
“"Tick tock", the cuckoo clock ticks.
"Cuckoo", the bird inside sings.
Tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock.
As ticks the time, so ticks your heart.
May you live long as you hear its song.
Tick tock tick tock tick tock tick tock.
Listen close, for when it stops
the hatchling comes out of its home.
Tick tock tick tock tick tock tick-
Did you hear it?
Did it stop?
My child, it meant your time was up.”
The research team theorizes that this nursery
rhyme, and others like it, was used to warn
children about potential indicators of danger
from SCP-4975, and teach them to be wary of
its hunting patterns.
Knowledge, after all, is one of the best weapons
in anyone’s arsenal when it comes to the
anomalous.
Without much more knowledge than this little
poem provides, and what they had observed
prior to SCP-4975’s capture, the SCP Foundation
did its best to create adequate containment
measures for the creature.
Currently, SCP-4975 is kept in a standard
steel containment cell, and is prohibited
from any direct human contact.
It can be observed via security footage, but
no human beings are permitted to go inside,
lest they serve as the creature’s next meal.
If a containment breach occurs, any personnel
that report hearing a repetitive cracking
or ticking sound are to be isolated until
the entity has been captured and placed back
in its cell, or until the sound stops.
Though SCP-4975 is currently contained, there
is a chance that it's captive state does not
actually make it any less lethal.
After a harrowing incident that sent many
attending researchers to
the on-site psychologist’s
office, the Foundation was given reason to
believe that containing it does not actually
stop it from hunting.
On September 16, 2002, something horrible
happened near the Black Forest in Germany.
A team of Foundation operatives had been placed
in the area to monitor a man from Freiburg
who had complained to the local police about
a clicking sound that had been following him
around for quite some time.
Over the course of four months of being unable
to escape the sound, or the feeling that he
was being watched no matter where he went,
he had become convinced that someone was stalking
him.
It was a bizarre situation, and he wasn’t
certain how his stalker was making this maddening
sound, but he believed his life to be in danger.
Concerned that this could be the work of SCP-4975,
the Foundation operatives took him into their
custody.
The police were given a cover story, claiming
that the man was experiencing a sense of paranoia
as well as auditory hallucinations as a result
of side effects from chemotherapy.
Once the Foundation operatives explained to
the man that they meant him no harm, believed
him about his fears, and wished to help, he
opened up about his experiences.
He told the operatives that, in addition to
the sound and the feeling of something following
him, he had seen a monstrous figure in the
woods.
He had kept this detail to himself when speaking
to the police, afraid they would have him
committed rather than listening to him.
The operatives asked him to lead them to the
place where he had seen the monster, and he
agreed.
The man led the team to a densely wooded part
of the forest, trees blocking out the sunlight
until their surroundings became as dark as
if it were the middle of the night.
As they walked deeper and deeper into the
forest, the man became increasingly anxious.
His breath came in short, strained gasps,
his eyes darted from tree to tree, and he
jumped at the slightest sound of a twig snapping
beneath someone’s foot or branches rustling
in a gust of wind.
Suddenly, mid-stride, he froze.
His eyes were wide, his face white as a sheet.
With a trembling hand, he pointed toward a
nearby tree.
In a voice so faint it was almost a whisper,
he said: “There.”
The operatives turned to look, but saw nothing
there.
The man repeated, “There!”
but they couldn’t see anything but the trees.
The man stumbled back, going weak at the knees
from pure terror, and continued to point at
the empty space next to the tree.
Just as one operative was turning to another
to comment that their witness must be out
of his mind, the man suddenly collapsed onto
the ground, as if an invisible, powerful force
had thrown him down.
The man screamed for help, struggling against
the unseen attacker as it slashed at his face
and his chest, tearing through fabric and
skin, blood spraying across the forest floor.
Two officers drew their weapons, firing at
where they guessed the assailant might be,
but their bullets ricocheted uselessly off
of nearby tree trunks.
Another rushed to the man on the ground, grabbed
him under the arms, and attempted to pull
him out of harm’s way.
However, the man would not budge, as the invisible
force held him in place, shredding through
his stomach as it fought to keep its prey.
Afraid to rip open the stomach wound any further,
the operative quickly ceased his attempts
to move the man.
Instead, he pulled out his weapon and did
the only merciful thing he could think to
do: he shot the local man in the head, putting
him out of his misery before he was ripped
to shreds.
The operatives watched, some in silent shock,
some continuing to fire their weapons, some
vomiting from sheer disgust, as strips of
the dead man’s flesh ripped off the bone
and disappeared, one piece at a time.
Meanwhile, thousands of miles away, surveillance
footage at SCP-4975’s containment site picked
up some peculiar activity in the creature’s
cell.
It stopped rotating its neck, which it had
done almost constantly since being captured,
and stared at the corner of its containment
cell.
Its eyes were wide, unblinking, and it did
not move a muscle.
It stayed still for several minutes, until
it eventually broke the unsettling stillness
to eat, greedily gobbling down slices of meat.
There was one problem, though.
The creature had not yet been fed that day.
All Foundation operatives dispatched to Germany
to investigate SCP-4975 were recalled back
to their original sites, and additional research
has been suspended until further notice.
In light of this new information, a motion
has been filed to reclassify the creature
as Keter, and potentially impossible to contain
with the Foundation’s current resources.
As terrible as it is to admit, this is one
monster the Foundation has not yet found a
way to stop.
They may have it locked in a cage, but it
can still hunt anyone, anywhere, any time
it wants to.
Wait a second.
Shh, be very quiet.
What’s that sound?
In your room, right now.
Listen closely.
Tick.
Do you hear it?
Don’t worry, it’s probably just a clock
or a kitchen timer.
Maybe it’s just your imagination.
Tick.
Whatever it is, I’m sure you’ll be fine.
There’s nothing dangerous about a weird
sound from time to time.
You don’t have anything to fear unless it
suddenly goes silent.
That’s when you’re really in trouble,
when you know what SCP-4975 is about to strike,
to devour you alive.
Wait.
Stop.
Hold your breath, don’t make a single peep.
Do you hear it?
Neither do I.
You hear their footsteps coming down the
halls. Or are those your own? Can you even
tell the difference? You can tell they’re
getting closer and you can feel the hate,
the rage. You turn, shaking, and
finally see them standing right
in front of you. But in that moment, you
might as well be looking into a mirror.
And who knows? Perhaps you are. You just don’t
seem to remember having so many reflections...
Have you ever heard the saying “You
are your own worst enemy?” Of course,
it isn’t usually meant literally. But what if it
was? What if you had to fight a monster…that was
you? All of your flaws are reflected back
at you. Your strengths, your weaknesses,
your deepest fears, with no way to escape
except a battle to the death. Either way,
you’re not making it out alive. It’s just a
matter of which version of you survives. But
this isn’t a thought experiment. No, according to
the findings of the SCP Foundation, it’s very much
a reality. There is a place where this nightmare
comes to life, and it is known as SCP-1919.
SCP-1919 is a hotel and converted mansion, built
in the early 20th century. From the outside,
it looks pretty much like it
did when it was first built,
and it almost looks like a comfortable
place to stay… if you ignore the eastern
side of the building that has
sunk partially into the ground.
The inside, however, is a different story, where
it’s clear the ravages of time have taken their
toll. The floorboards and ceilings are rotting,
collapsing in on themselves, and the rooms are
filled with debris. It’s deadly enough to explore
the hotel for these reasons alone, but this is
only the beginning of the danger for a person
inside. In order to determine just how dangerous
it is for either one person or group to enter the
structure, the SCP Foundation planned a series of
research expeditions into the abandoned building,
led by Foundation scientist Dr. Limkiewicz.
The first expedition seemed relatively
normal, at least it did at the start. A
39-year-old Caucasian D-Class male known as
D7 was sent into the structure with a camera
and a communications system, guided remotely by
Dr. Limkiewicz, or Dr. L, and another operative,
a former head of the MTF Tau-11 “Youth Hostiles”
who is referred to in this file only as T11.
When he arrived at the building, D7 was
unable to get inside through the front
door or windows. After several minutes of
trial and error, he was finally able to
get in through the western entrance. Dr. L
picked up a strange, high-pitched whistling
noise upon D7’s entrance into the building,
but it quickly faded away and was disregarded
by T11. D7 discovered a torn painting, a
portrait of a young woman with red hair.
Next to the portrait, shallow scratches
could be seen in the wall, the floor,
and parts of the ceiling. Suddenly, D7 ducked
into a hiding place, alarmed. He, and the other
two operatives listening to his audio feed could
hear heavy breathing… and it didn’t belong to D7.
Dr. L recommended that D7 evacuate the
building at this sign of another entity
inside, but T11 overruled, ordering him to
disregard that instruction and continue his
investigation. D7 was told to stay at a safe
distance from whatever was inside with him,
and attempt to capture it on video. D7 turned
off his flashlight in order to better hide, but
T11 commanded that he turn it back on. Whatever
was caught in its beam of light was difficult for
the camera to see, but it threw D7 into a panic
and he began to run in the opposite direction.
When prompted to explain what he
saw, D7 simply said: “It was me!”
D7 ran through the dark, panting with fear
and exertion. Unable to see where his feet
were landing, he tripped over something
and came crashing onto the ground,
dropping the video camera. This allowed the
observing officers to finally see what D7
was so frightened by, and it became
clear just why D7 was so terrified.
A man, identical looking to D7, approached from
the end of the hallway, making its way toward
the real D7. It was followed by another
man who also resembled D7, and another,
all running toward the original.
They all looked exactly like him,
with a few notable differences. They
were dressed in the same uniform,
with the same build and the same features,
but each had something slightly off about him.
One was missing eyelids,
another had malformed hands,
and the third had its lips fused together
into a fleshy mass beneath its nose.
Dr. L moved to cut the camera feed, but T11
demanded that it be kept running. D7 couldn’t
be seen by the camera, but the microphone picked
up the sounds of flesh and cloth being torn, along
with pained, panicked screams as the duplicates
set upon him. After a moment, the screaming
stopped. Two hours later, the camera was broken,
and the expedition brought to a troubling end.
This was the Foundation’s first glimpse
at the creatures inside of SCP-1919,
and it was not pretty. It did, however, allow them
to begin understanding the nature of the building,
and what happens when a person goes inside.
It appears that when a human enters the hotel,
several humanoid creatures manifest throughout the
building. These creatures look like the subject,
and are equipped with the same clothing or items
that the subject brought inside with them. Though
they are nearly mirror images of the subject, they
are always slightly warped in a variety of ways.
These have included changes to limb and digit
length, joint mobility, sealed nostrils,
lengthened jaws hanging loose and limp,
missing eyelids, and lips that are fused
together. These creatures are highly aggressive
toward the structure of the building itself,
as well as to the subject that they resemble.
They do not, however, attack each other. They
appear to operate with a hive mind, exhibiting
swarm intelligence like that of an ant colony.
Once they have been spawned by
the entrance of a new person,
they will not stop until said person
either escapes the building or is killed.
After the unfortunate end to the first
expedition, the Foundation prepped for
a second trip inside. This time, three men were
sent in with Dr. L’s guidance, known as D3, D4,
and D9. Video cameras were sewn into their clothes
to leave their hands free and to help avoid some
of the issues that came up during the first
expedition. This small team was sent in with
the orders to terminate the remaining copies of
D7, and further examine the hotel’s interior.
Upon opening the door to the building, they
were immediately attacked by one of D7’s copies,
which D9 was able to quickly dispatch
by firing his weapon at its head. Next,
after a great deal of reluctance, the three
men entered the building where they spotted
something unusual inside. Dr. L was horrified
when the camera feed revealed seventeen
discarded video cameras spread across the floor.
They didn’t have much time to
react to this new discovery,
however, because two doubles, one
mirroring D7 and another mirroring D9,
emerged from the wall and began to attack.
Dr. L ordered the team to take shelter,
then called the team of guards outside of
the hotel’s perimeter. They were ordered
to begin an immediate full perimeter lockdown,
preventing the doubles from leaving the hotel.
D3, D4, and D9 attempted to make their
way to a safe corner of the building,
but found themselves met with a murderous double
at every turn. At this point, Dr. L began to hear
an unusual sound over the microphone feed, a
high-pitched whine like that of a dentist’s
drill. The operatives on the ground couldn’t hear
a thing, but on Dr. L’s end it was deafening.
As the team proceeded deeper into the hotel,
they became overcome with a strange feeling
of foreboding. Dr. L ordered them to turn
on their flashlights, but they refused and
begged Dr. L to keep quiet. When prompted
to explain, D9 said: “she can hear you.”
The operatives stopped responding,
but their camera feeds caught a faint,
glowing white light coming from
beneath a door. The door opened,
and the light flooded the camera, making
the images it captured hard to decipher.
Just a few frames of a quick-moving female
silhouette were captured before the cameras
cut to static. The bodies of D3, D4, and D9
were never recovered, nor were their cameras.
A third expedition was also sent into SCP-1919,
but very little is known about what occurred
during it. The video transcript is highly
classified and only those present for its events,
or approved to research SCP-1919, have access
to it. An update to the SCP-1919 file following
Expedition Three though, indicates that
new information was revealed about the
hotel during the excursion. According to the
file update, there is some kind of being at
the center of the location which is causing all
of the other creatures, the doubles, to appear.
The only information available about this
being is the use of the word “her” in the
official Foundation log about SCP-1919. This
seems to match up with the last moments of
the operatives in Expedition Two, when they
told Dr. L that “she can hear you” and the
few frames of a female figure that were
captured by their cameras. Nothing else
is known that has been made available
to anyone outside a very select few.
Only the original report exists, and all
other copies of it have been destroyed.
The Foundation has undertaken special containment
procedures to make sure that none of the entities
from inside the hotel escape, whether they are
the “evil twins” spawned by humans entering
the building, or the mysterious female being at
the center of the entire disturbing phenomenon.
The Foundation has classified SCP-1919
as Euclid and a two kilometer radius
must be maintained around SCP-1919, with all
roads leading to the building are blocked or
diverted so that no vehicles are able to
reach it. This perimeter is guarded by a
set of at least forty armed and armored guards
at any given time. As it has been determined
that the doubles spawned by 1919 are equipped
with whatever the human they are copying has,
no one is allowed to enter the hotel
with body armor or weapons of any kind.
Anyone that approaches the perimeter that is
not part of an official expedition team will
be immediately terminated. No new expeditions
teams are allowed to enter the building unless
all doubles from the previous expedition
have been exterminated. In the event that
they cannot be exterminated, enough time
must elapse between expeditions that the
previous doubles have starved to death.
Though they do not seem to feel hunger,
the doubles do need to eat to survive, and
will die when left alone for long enough.
SCP-1919 has been sealed off from the rest of
the world, so that no hapless civilians can
wander inside and find themselves torn to
pieces by warped images of themselves. But
that comfort turns cold when you realize that
the SCP Foundation still does not understand
what causes these doubles to spawn. Is it
scientific? Supernatural? Or something else?
No one can be certain. Even more inexplicable
is the entity at the center of all this,
an unknown female presence capable of wreaking
frightening amounts of violence by turning
victims’ own images against them. What is the
purpose of these funhouse mirror nightmares?
Who is she, what is she, and what does she
want? Currently, the doubles have shown no
interest in leaving the hotel except to attack
intruders, and thanks to that fact, as well as
the reinforced perimeter outside, these copycats
have not appeared outside of the building itself.
But what happens if they do escape,
or if the entity that controls them
decides to make her home elsewhere? There
is no telling what could happen if this
dark power is allowed to move
beyond its current containment.
Are you prepared to fight a vision of yourself,
twisted almost beyond recognition, lunging after
you with wide bulbous eyes, unnaturally long arms,
and a distended jaw hanging down below its
neck? Better hope you never have to find out.
Like any other area in the United States,
the state of Florida has a healthy share of
urban legends and local myths.
Take for example the legendary Swamp Ape,
the region’s bigfoot equivalent, a hulking
creature said to run amok in the state’s
many swamps and aquatic areas, identified
by its strong, repugnant odor and deep, guttural
throat-calls.
Or the ghosts of the St. Augustine lighthouse,
a grizzly tale revolving around two young
girls who drowned in the nearby sea while
their mother was working the lighthouse, too
distracted to hear the cries of her children
as they were swallowed by the current and
returned to the brine.
It’s rumored that on some nights, the twins'
laughter and cries are heard from the top
of the lighthouse.
Not scary enough?
What about the devil’s chair?
A seemingly ordinary bench located in the
town of Cassadaga that was supposedly built
by the devil himself.
Every night, at midnight, the man in red returns
to his bench, and if you sit beside him, he’ll
whisper wicked, horrible things into your
ear, leaving you forever scarred and haunted
by the experience.
Just don’t leave a drink behind when you
run off the bench in terror though, another
legend says that any unopened bottles left
on the bench will mysteriously be opened and
drained by the morning.
Torturing damned souls for eternity makes
you a thirsty guy, we guess.
But to a seasoned viewer of SCP Explained,
urban legends and local oddities might seem
a bit mundane in comparison to the strange,
inexplicable anomalies that the SCP Foundation
regularly researches and contains.
After all, the truth is almost always stranger
than fiction, and if an actual anomaly gets
picked up as an urban legend, the SCP Foundation
is going to do everything in their power to
shut it down, cover it up, and make the story
a little more digestible for the general public.
That means relying on the same, tired tropes
and cliches we’ve all heard before.
Cursed dolls, bigfoot-like creatures, ghost
hitchhikers, we all know them, and as fun
as they are, the most popular stories aren’t
always the most unique or interesting.
And if you peer deeper underneath the surface,
you can always find kernels of truth in the
most commonplace of legends.
For example, what’s commonly referred to
as bigfoot, or sasquatch, is actually SCP-1000,
a super-intelligent, prehistoric race of ape
creatures known as the Children of the Night,
who were slaughtered by early humans and forced
to hide from the world in order to preserve
their species.
A cursed object or location?
The Foundation deals with those all of the
time, and stories of ghosts are as commonplace
in the anomalous world as they are in the
ordinary one.
But what about an anomaly that utilizes urban
legends to further its own nefarious goals?
One that’s lifeblood is localized to a single
area?
Today on SCP Explained, we’re going to be
talking about SCP-3640, an
anomaly that capitalizes
on the interest and intrigue those urban legends
generate.
Specifically those in the state of Florida.
We already talked about the variety of weird
and creepy stories the state calls its own,
but what else is Florida known for?
Tourism?
Retirement communities?
Beautiful, summer weather?
Slightly crazy individuals making news headlines
for ridiculous reasons?
How about Disney?
That’s right, the state of Florida is known
for Walt Disney World, the granddaddy of all
theme parks that brings in millions of tourist
dollars annually, and the hub for some of
the most iconic characters and stories in
the world.
If you’ve ever been to Disney World, then
you know about the costumed characters that
roam the park.
Silent, mascot costume renditions of your
favorite TV and movie characters, posing for
pictures and having fun with children.
The park is practically infested with them.
They seem inescapable!
It’s pretty understandable that some people
are unsettled by mascots, they can sometimes
be downright creepy.
With those unmoving expressions, giant heads,
unnatural movements, and the faces of familiar
fictional characters, in the right context,
a mascot can be just as scary as any horror
movie monster or urban legend could ever be.
Here’s a situation for you.
You just landed at a Florida airport, you’re
ready to go to Disney World and enjoy a vacation
after you’ve been worked to exhaustion as
a junior researcher at the SCP Foundation.
You want to get familiar with the state, but
you’re trying to cut down on your phone
usage.
After all, you’re on vacation, why not do
things the old fashioned way and unplug from
the electronics?
You spot a brochure rack in the distance,
perfect!
A paper hub for everything tourist-y in the
area.
Among the hundreds of jet skiing courses,
beach information, and mini golf pamphlets,
one brochure in particular stands out to you.
Maybe it’s your background in the anomalous,
but you just can’t help yourself from picking
up a booklet on Florida’s urban legends.
Knowing what’s behind the curtain, working
for the SCP Foundation, really makes these
types of things more amusing.
You’ve seen how the sausage was made, and
it’s a lot more terrifying than anything
known to the general public.
Heck, you know for a fact that the organization
you work for has more likely than not covered
up most of the actual incidents that inspired
these local legends.
Nonetheless, you pick up the brochure, interested
in the self-guided tour of Florida’s paranormal
hotspots, and you’re impressed to find that
this booklet has it all.
Everything from Skunk Apes to a cursed doll,
it’s all in here.
You chuckle, and tuck the pamphlet underneath
your arm.
But little do you know, you’re about to
experience something more horrifying than
any urban legend could ever be.
You see, if you paid attention to your Foundation
briefings before you left the state for Florida,
you would know that any Foundation personnel
who encounter tourist
brochure pamphlets advertising
self-guided paranormal tours in Florida are
to bring said pamphlets to the Foundation’s
attention immediately.
Mobile Task Force Lambda-12, nicknamed “Pest
Control”, is primed on-demand for incidents
related to these brochurces.
Why?
Because they’re a part of a phenomenon categorized
by the SCP Foundation as SCP-3640.
But what is SCP-3640?
Why is something as innocuous and fun as a
paranormal travel brochure an object of high
interest for the SCP Foundation?
Well, you, someone who should have maybe listened
to the regional briefing conferences back
at Site-19 before you left on your vacation,
are about to find out.
After pursuing your booklet and ruminating
over the numerous locations at your disposal,
you decide to visit one after you get settled
into your hotel.
After all, you’re about to experience a
week of family-friend fun at the House of
Mouse, why not partake in a little horror
just to get the blood pumping?
A bit of living life on the edge before the
scariest thing you have to deal with is a
$10 bottle of water and a three hour waiting
line to ride that giant golf ball.
You drive all the way out to the location
the pamphlet specified, a bridge by the name
of Sunshine Skyway, located right outside
of Tampa Bay.
Visiting the bridge at night might also get
you a visit from a mysterious and beautiful
hitchhiker woman, who stands on the side of
the bridge and attempts to flag down cars.
If you happen to take her in, she’ll begin
to weep, growing progressively louder and
louder in her screaming and crying until you
reach the other side of the bridge.
And when the driver turns back to ask her
what’s wrong, the woman will have vanished
without a trace.
Sounds like a fun time, right?
Maybe you can find her.
Heck, maybe she’s single and interested
in an enthusiastic and kind junior researcher
of the SCP Foundation?
You would never contain her, you’d promise,
having to raise your voice over the sounds
of her weeping and crying in the backseat
of your car.
Or, maybe not.
This vacation time outside of the lab is making
you think some strange, strange stuff.
Whatever the case is, you want to see a ghost
girl, so you make your way over to the Sunshine
Skyway at 11 at night, just like the pamphlet
specified.
The bridge is strangely empty, especially
for what’s usually a crowded stretch of
the road.
In fact, now that you realize it, there’s
no one else here.
Just you, your car, the black night sky, and
the sound of your humming engine.
Well, up the road you go, looking for this
supposed ghost hitchhiker.
The Skyway is quite the drive, and the longer
you ride, the less safe you feel.
But you’re fine, right?
It’s a very popular bridge, driven by thousands
of people every day and night.
It just so happens to be completely empty
at an ordinary time of night, and that you
can see the dark outline of a figure in the
distance, standing in the middle of the road.
As you drive closer and closer, you start
to make out the figure a bit more.
A circular head, a tall, wide body, and two
more circles on top of that round, ball head.
Closer, a little closer, and… wait, is that-
There’s absolutely no way that’s who you
think it is.
Is that a Mickey Mouse costume standing in
the middle of the road?
It apparently is, and it seems like it’s
not getting out of the way.
You honk your horn, but the overgrown rat
doesn’t listen, it’s still standing there,
unmoving.
You slow down.
You know what Disney’s legal team is capable
of and you are absolutely not going to go
to jail for running over Mickey Mouse, so
if he’s not moving out of the way, you will
instead.
You try to maneuver around the stationary
mascot, but suddenly, out of nowhere, the
thing leaps fifteen feet into the air and
jumps onto your hood.
You scream as the Mickey mascot scitters across
the roof of your car, clawing and tearing
at the sunroof, trying to get in.
You push your foot on the gas as hard as you
can, with enough force to propel Mickey from
the roof, but it’s not enough.
The mascot hits the ground, but immediately
gets back up and starts running after your
car.
Almost instantaneously, it catches up to your
car again, and uses its strength to pry off
the door on the driver’s side of the car,
exposing you and causing you to lose control
of your vehicle.
You swerve, crashing into the side of the
bridge and banging your head off of the steering
wheel.
You never thought your life would result in
death by Mickey Mouse, but the rapidly approaching
costumed creature seems to be saying otherwise.
The Mickey creature bends down, and uses both
of its gloved hands to grab you from your
car seat with enough force to break the seatbelt
and give you minor whiplash from being flung
into the air so quickly.
This is it, you know it’s over, and you
don’t even know what’s going on or why
this is happening.
You’re just another victim of something
you don’t understand, like the countless
dead you spent your life researching.
Or so you think.
Just when you assume that it’s all over,
a shot rings out from across the bridge, and
you see a salvo of bullets pepper Mickey Mouse’s
back, carefully missing you with impressively
accurate precision.
Mickey drops you, banging your head on the
concrete, and runs towards where the bullets
are coming from.
Several armored, heavily armed soldiers appear
from the side of the bridge and circle the
mouse.
They fire again, but it has little effect
on the mascot.
Once again, he lunges forward, knocking a
soldier off his feet.
The mascot dashes off into the distance, leaping
over the side of the bridge.
Though no splash is heard in the water below,
you don’t see the mascot landing or even
escaping.
It’s like he was never there in the first
place.
But at least it’s gone now, and you have
these unknown soldiers to thank for your,
wait, is that an SCP Foundation logo?
Oh no, they’re Foundation Task Force operatives.
Before you’re able to fully regain your
senses, you can already hear the Task Force
captain telling his underling to prep you
for amnestics and an interview.
The soldier approaches you, and you’re thankfully
able to muster out a few choice words.
Namely, “Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait!
I’m with you guys!
I’m a junior researcher!”
The captain pauses and laughs to himself.
What are the odds?
After you’re processed and taken to the
nearest facility, where your identity as a
card carrying member of the SCP Foundation
is confirmed, you’re let in on what exactly
it was that you just saw back there.
As it turns out, you had an encounter with
SCP-3640, an anomaly centering around a set
of travel brochures that advertise self-guided
tours of all of Florida’s paranormal hotspots.
If someone reads the brochure and goes to
a location at a set time, just like you did,
they’ll be preyed upon by a mysterious,
predatory entity or set of entities that resemble
costumed mascot characters owned by the Walt
Disney Company.
Mickey, Donald, Goofy, the task force captain
explains that they’re all there, and they’re
all over the state of Florida.
Hundreds of mascots, maybe more.
They’re fast, dangerous, and the Foundation
knows remarkably little about them.
Including how they grow, reproduce, or even
consume their prey.
All of the known hotspots advertised in the
pamphlet are routinely watched by members
of the Pest Control mobile task force, where
operatives are authorized to neutralize SCP-3640
entities with lethal force.
Which is how that Task
Force was able to thankfully
show up at the right moment and save your
life.
SCP-3640 only attack those who read the brochures,
and haven’t been seen being hostile or hunting
outside of the areas specified by the pamphlet.
After you recollect yourself and thank them,
the captain hands you a file briefing on SCP-3640,
gives you a stern warning, and tells you to
familiarize yourself with it before you leave
the facility.
What a way to start your vacation, you think.
Just when you thought you were able to escape
the daily horrors of working for the Foundation,
you stumble onto an anomaly yourself.
But you undoubtedly have more questions about
SCP-3640.
After all, anyone would after witnessing as
weird and strange an anomaly as that in the
wild.
You ask the captain why the Foundation hasn’t
captured an SCP-3640 instance, especially
if they’re so common in the Florida area.
He sits down, sighs, and explains that the
Foundation did try, awhile back.
It was a standard D-Class test, held in the
St. Johns River, the location of a supposed
“river monster”.
The D-Class personnel was dropped off at the
river bank and told to follow the instructions
in the pamphlet.
If they spotted a mascot, they were to shoot
at it with a tranquilizer gun.
After dredging through the river for a few
minutes and being distracted by a neat looking
alligator, the D-Class eventually came head
to head with none other than Donald Duck himself,
who emerged from the river and immediately
began moving towards the D-Class.
The D-Class naturally freaked out completely,
and ran away from the scene, but Donald was
simply too fast.
Just when he thought he was safe, the Donald
mascot emerged from the shadows and knocked
the camera and radio off of the D-Class’s
head.
There were sounds of a struggle, but the D-Class
never established contact again.
However, his subdermal tracking transmitters
continued to operate, and before they went
offline completely, they luckily detected
the location of the D-Class’s body.
It was just outside of the EPCOT amusement
park.
Engaged by the captain’s story, you ask
him what happened next.
Surely, the Foundation launched an assault
on EPCOT to figure out what happened to the
D-Class, right?
The captain grunts, and tells you that the
rest is classified.
But you’re not satisfied.
You’re refusing to move until you figure
out what happened to this D-Class.
The captain rolls his eyes, and perhaps feeling
sorry for you, decides to tell you the rest
of the story.
Him and his team were deployed just outside
of the EPCOT theme park, right next to a one
story, concrete hut, where the D-Class’s
location was tracked.
They were equipped with heavy arms, a net
launcher, and a flamethrower, all perfect
weapons for subduing these deadly mascots.
While Lambda-12 was typically used to hunting
anomalous bugs and pests, they figured that
hunting down Donald Duck and Minnie Mouse
was more or less the same thing, when you
squint really hard and pretend that they have
wings.
The task force broke into the hut, revealing
it to be a maintenance shed with a mysterious
trap door in the middle of the floor.
Underneath, a ladder led to a tunnel system,
similar to the ones built underneath the Disney
Parks that the employees use to get around
from park to park.
The team spotted several dressing rooms and
storage rooms, all empty and devoid of any
life.
After some exploration, the team followed
a low rumbling noise to a closed door.
They slowly opened it, revealing an abandoned
boiler room, with a white mascot costume at
the foot of the boiler, curled up around an
unknown object.
An operative approached the costume and poked
it with her rifle, identifying it as an empty
Daisy Duck costume.
The team examined it further, and found a
human arm bone inside the suit.
Disgusting, to be sure, but nothing the task
force hadn’t seen before.
They turned over the suit to examine the object
it was curled around, discovering it to be
a purple, plastic egg, with an embryo inside.
Scattered across the floor were more eggshells.
The squad gathered them, as well as the bones
of the D-Class in the costume, to bring back
to the facility.
Suddenly, the task force heard noises in the
distance, and assumed an attack formation.
They noticed the floor of the entrance they
came in was now covered in dark fluid and
polyester stuffing.
The trail of liquid exactly matched their
path of infiltration into the tunnel.
After determining the situation to be safe,
the squad carefully left the tunnel the way
they came, bringing the costume and the egg
with them.
After several weeks, the egg hatched into
a miniature stuffed donald duck toy.
The Foundation dissected it, discovering it
to contain a plastic
endoskeleton and a rudimentary
polyester stuffing muscular system inside.
And that was everything the captain had to
say.
There was never any other leads on the SCP-3640
anomaly, just strangeness and inexplicable
inability to capture or understand the mascots.
You thanked the captain for not only saving
you, but explaining what was going on.
Before you left the facility to go back to
your regular, foundation-less vacation, you
took another glance at the document the Captain
handed to you.
On the back page was a chilling letter, dated
from 1979, written to Florida governor Reuben
Askew by the Walt Disney Company.
It read:
The Walt Disney Company thanks you for your
cooperation in this matter
regarding the unlicensed
Walt Disney character operators.
Please pass along the following information,
collected by the outstanding men and women
of the City of Orlando's Police Department,
to the Florida National Guard:
If a character is spotted, call to get its
attention and then rapidly flash your flashlights
at the costume.
If it does not flinch, fire on sight.
Aim at the head if possible; else, aim at
the knees to disable them and then finish
them off with head shots.
Body shots have been shown to lack effectiveness.
Deceased characters are to be incinerated.
No other means of disposal are advised.
We are currently pursuing alternative legal
means of shutting down these unlicensed operators
and hope to achieve a settlement within the
end of the year.
Cordially yours,
The Walt Disney Company
Take a brief moment to think back to your
younger years, spending long, tiresome hours
trapped in a classroom, waiting to hear the
noise of that final bell of the day.
That sound meant freedom, the end of another
grueling six hours at your desk, and the chance
to get back to the warm sanctuary of home.
If you were lucky, you might not have had
to go far to get back to the safety and security
of being in your parents’ house, living
close enough to the school would mean you
could easily walk home when the day was through.
But your classmates?
Well, they weren’t all as lucky, some of
them had miles to travel, all the way across
town even.
Fortunately, though, the school bus would
always be waiting outside at the end of each
day, ready to take a gaggle of rowdy kids
back home.
And if you were one of those kids that had
to take the bus, you’ll know that the trip
home after school was hardly a calm drive.
Paper planes and spitballs firing from all
directions, wads of chewing gum stuck to the
undersides of the seats, other kids all around
you screaming and yelling at the top of their
lungs.
Still, it could be worse, right?
No, trust us, it could be much, much worse
than you can ever imagine.
What if, one day, the bus that picked you
up from school wasn’t a bus at all?
What if, instead, it was SCP-2086?
Picture this: One day, you get put in detention
at school.
Maybe you were disrupting a class or got caught
spraying graffiti on the outside wall of the
gym.
Whatever the reason, we’re sure you think
it’s unfair that you got held back after
school, after everyone else had already gone
home.
But you do your time, until finally, you’re
told you can leave.
Problem is, your house is on the other side
of town, and you’ve already missed the bus.
You make your way off the campus, down the
nearest street.
Maybe there’s a city bus you can catch that’ll
get you home.
As you stroll away from your school, you realize
that the nearest bus stop, the first one on
the route home, seems to be further away than
you remember it being.
Must just be the exhaustion of a long day
getting the better of you, playing tricks
on your mind.
It’s not like someone could move the bus
stop, right?
Finally reaching the stop, you notice lights
coming down the street after a few moments
of waiting quietly.
A late bus, just like you hoped for.
It pulls up next to the stop, the doors folding
open to allow you on board.
It’s totally empty, save for the driver.
But straight away, you notice there’s something
odd about him.
He seems drained of color, his movements are
weird, more like a puppet on strings than
an actual living, breathing human being.
Now you think about it, if it wasn’t for
the fact he was clearly moving, driving the
bus, you might assume that he was a corpse.
Then again, maybe he just had a long day too.
Taking a seat, you try not to think about
it, and stare out of the window in boredom.
You watch as the route takes you past stop
after stop, all of them empty just like the
bus itself.
But then something unexpected happens.
You’ve ridden the bus to and from school
so many times before that you can’t help
but notice when, for some reason, it takes
a wrong turn.
Looking out the window you know you aren’t
mistaken.
The driver has changed direction, instead
of heading towards the nearest stop to home,
he’s taken the bus towards the furthest
edge of town.
Desperately you try yelling at him, asking
why he’s taken the wrong turn, but the driver
stays still, as if he can’t even hear what
you’re saying.
That’s when you notice the smell.
You didn’t catch it before, but now it’s
all around you, filling the air inside the
bus.
It’s almost like the scent of disinfectant;
the bus now smells the same way a hospital
does.
But that’s not all.
The more you breathe it in, the more you feel
yourself starting to get woozy, arms and legs
getting heavier.
Everything around you feels as if it’s spinning
uncontrollably.
Out of the windows, you can just about make
out the sight of a junkyard, blurring in and
out of focus.
It’s meant to be abandoned, and yet you’re
sure you can see movement: Massive, indeterminate
shapes shifting around in the dark.
Finally, your vision goes dark and you fall
unconscious onto the floor of the bus.
Only you were never on the bus to begin with.
No, although you didn’t know it, you were
prey to something that just looked like a
bus: SCP-2086.
And now that it’s caught you, you’ll never
see the light of day again.
Now, SCP-2086 doesn’t just refer to a single
creature, not by a long shot.
It’s the designation given to an entire
species of arthropods; think lobsters, crabs,
and spiders, or insects like centipedes and
millipedes.
Only much bigger.
To the untrained eye, and depending on when
you look, an instance of SCP-2086 will normally
look like any ordinary public transport vehicle,
of any make and model, or belonging to any
company or transit authority.
Usually, though, they look like regular old
buses, at least while they’re out foraging
for food.
When born, an SCP-2086 specimen will grow
to full juvenile size within a week, usually
weighing two hundred kilograms or less.
Fully matured adult instances, however, can
weigh approximately seventeen thousand kilograms.
The adults are the ones that go out foraging,
leaving the nest to collect food to then bring
back to the juvenile SCP-2086s.
And by food, we of course mean humans.
While out on the roads, matured SCP-2086 creatures
are practically identical to the auto vehicles
that form their bodies.
But the materials that this disguise is made
from – the steel, plastic, wood, and glass
– they’re all actually comprised of specialized
chitin, the kind of outer shell you’ll find
on most arthropods.
But underneath that outer shell, that’s
where you’ll find the real horror.
Within the main chamber, beneath the flooring
of the bus’s long, inner portion, is stored
the pulsing, beating heart of an SCP-2086
specimen.
And we don’t mean that in a metaphorical
sense, if you were to lift up the floorboards
of one of these bus-like creatures you’d
see its heart, along with other vital organs
like the creature’s brain and stomach.
What’s more, that figure in the front seat,
that you thought was a living, breathing bus
driver, actually isn’t living or breathing,
not anymore.
Preserved in a shellac substance that the
creature is able to produce, this driver is
actually a human corpse, acting as a decoy
for SCP-2086s.
From within the bus body, fibrous appendages
reach up into the corpse, almost like incredibly
thin hairs.
The creature can then use the cadaver essentially
as a puppet, a puppet with a dead person’s
body.
That’s how an SCP-2086 is able to move its
driver around, making it appear more lifelike
so it can lure its prey aboard.
Think of it like the bioluminescent light
that anglerfish use to tempt unsuspecting
fish into their jaws.
Same principle, but with a dramatically different
result when it comes to SCP-2086.
But if you thought bus creatures with internal
organs under the floor and dead meat puppets
in the driver’s seat weren’t creepy enough,
there’s still much more to SCP-2086s than
meets the eye.
For example, when they aren’t out foraging,
the adult creatures can unravel the roof of
their bus-shaped outer shell.
Underneath is a pair of wings, large enough
and strong enough to carry their entire, several
thousand kilos of weight off the ground and
up into the air.
As for eyes?
The headlights at the front are, in actual
fact, bioluminescent optical organs, allowing
the creatures to see their prey even in the
dark.
Still not horrifying enough?
Well, would knowing about their legs help?
The wheels underneath an SCP-2086 specimen
are also capable of unraveling, forming long,
grey, or black legs, like those of a spider.
Yes, these are bus creatures with wings and
multi-jointed legs.
These legs aren’t just big, clumsy appendages
either.
Compared with other arthropods, SCP-2086s
are able to use their limbs
to perform surprisingly
intricate actions and finer
levels of manipulations.
For instance, a number of specimens have been
observed in the wild, by the SCP Foundation,
building shelters out of any materials that
they can find near their nesting ground.
And where do they normally nest?
Wherever there’s plenty of scrap metal,
and hardly any people to notice them.
Junkyards are the preferred habitats of SCP-2086s,
and where they will normally establish their
colonies.
While the juveniles remain within the confines
of the colony, adult SCP-2086 specimens will
leave to collect humans.
Although, on occasion, the younger specimens
have been known to travel out from their nest
and rearrange or relocate signposts for bus
stops.
They then place them in a route that leads
back towards their nesting ground; it’s
something worth remembering if your nearest
bus stop ever seems to be a little further
away from the school than usual.
Afterward, the older specimens will travel
along the route laid out
by the juvenile SCP-2086s,
picking up any human passengers that they
find waiting at the relocated bus stops.
They have to choose their moments wisely,
with people boarding and disembarking from
the bus usually every few stops.
Once an SCP-2086 has as many humans on board
as it can carry, with the certainty it won’t
lose any at the upcoming stop, it secretes
a substance similar to chloroform.
This fills the inner chamber of the bus, causing
that noxious smell, like hospital disinfectant.
The chloroform-like substance incapacitates
all the passengers on board, rendering them
unconscious and readying them to be taken
back to the local SCP-2086 colony.
Once the adult SCP-2086 has arrived at the
junkyard, the juveniles will descend on it.
Given their much, much smaller size, they
will climb inside the mature specimen and
forcibly remove each and every human passenger
it is carrying within.
Then comes the truly nasty part: feeding time.
Each juvenile SCP-2086 will force their captive
human through an orifice that is located under
the front hood of their vehicle shell.
This sphincter, a circular formation of muscle
that can expand and contract to perform a
bodily function, is connected to where the
steering wheel is found on an adult SCP-2086.
The younger creatures will push their human
prey through this sphincter, consuming them.
Once this has occurred, those hairy appendages
in the driver’s seat will then latch onto
the body of the now-dead human, piercing through
their skin, winding up and around their bones.
These are the same fibrous hairs used to puppet
the deceased corpse and use it to lure others
aboard the bus, but these appendages have
another function: they’re feeding tubes.
They will drain every last drop of blood from
the SCP-2086’s prey, until the body is little
more than a husk.
At which point, the tubes inject a saline
solution directly into the cadaver.
Afterwards, the inside of the bus fills with
that same substance that preserves the corpse,
and the process is complete.
As horrifying as these creatures are, one
of the few upsides of SCP-2086s is that they
don’t live very long.
Female specimens will reproduce after eight
days, and produce twenty offspring after this
point.
Each of these newborns reaches full maturity
and size in about a week.
On average, SCP-2086s live for twelve to fifteen
days.
Another net positive is, because of their
short lifespans, an SCP-2086 specimen doesn’t
need to feed on a human more than once, as
the nutrients it absorbs as a juvenile are
enough to sustain it through adulthood.
Once it has matured, an SCP-2086 will go out
into the nearest city or town to forage for
humans, providing food to the next generation.
And so, the cycle continues.
In the future, rather than take the bus, maybe
it’s safer to walk.
It might mean the difference between you making
it home, or becoming food.
October, 1988.
SCP Foundation Agents Cyril Novak and Diana
Fischer had been dispatched to Austria’s
capital city, Vienna, to investigate a series
of mysterious, unexplained disappearances.
The Foundation was unsure if these events
were connected, or even anomalous in nature,
but they had reason to believe that something
was lurking beneath the dark streets of Vienna.
A Foundation operative embedded in law enforcement
informed the organization that the authorities
were panicking, with an emphasis on withholding
information about these disappearances from
the public and the media.
Novak and Fischer conducted a survey of the
city, observing the streets at night and keeping
a watchful eye on those who they deemed at-risk.
It was the undesirables of society that were
disappearing in droves.
Unsupervised children, vagrants, the homeless.
All those that were indisposed, vulnerable,
and otherwise at risk of being forgotten by
society were potential victims.
According to several sources, these disappearances
were taking place near access points to the
city’s subterranean infrastructure.
Sewer holes, access tunnels, storm drains.
Anywhere that led to the underground was a
potential risk-site.
After a few days of standard exploration and
information gathering around Vienna, Novak
and Fishcer moved on to interviews with law
enforcement and public officials.
Using a variety of cover stories, they managed
to pry out a deadly secret from the mouth
of the police chief.
Human remains had been recovered near the
disappearance sites.
The authorities opted to keep them a secret
from the public, so as to not cause any panic
of a crazed serial killer on the loose, or
inspire fears of something even worse lurking
the city’s underground.
The Agents seized the three cadavers, and
alerted the Foundation that their mission
had been progressing as expected.
The bodies were transported
to Humanoid Containment
Site-282 in Graz, Austria, where they were
immediately examined by Dr. Felix Gärtner,
who performed an autopsy on the three corpses.
If the Foundation was unsure about anomalous
involvement before, they were certain of it
now.
The bodies were in shambles, mutilated beyond
belief and altered into an almost unrecognizable
state.
The mere stench of them caused personnel working
with them to rush to the bathroom, and even
those that could typically keep their lunch
down had a difficult time examining them.
Cadaver-A was in pieces, and the cause of
death was determined to be from exsanguination,
or the extreme loss of blood.
Cadaver-B was missing some important fleshy
components inside and out, some of which had
been removed entirely.
The cause of death was presumed to be traumatic
cardiac arrest.
The third corpse, Cadaver-C, was barely a
body.
Instead, it was a collection of bones and
fluids.
The cause of death, because of the opaque
conditions the cadaver was found in, was unknown.
These grizzly deaths were only the start of
the Foundation’s containment of this anomaly,
and are far from the worst this file has to
offer.
This is SCP Explained, and today we’re going
to be looking at SCP-3288, a collection of
entities otherwise known as The Aristocrats.
Dr. Gartner’s analysis of the cadavers came
to a single conclusion: a human could not
do this.
In fact, he compared the deceased’s injuries
and conditions with the bodies of victims
of hyena attacks.
All sustained injuries weren’t the result
of a blunt object, sharpened blade, or a firearm,
but instead resulted from a combination of
teeth, claws, and raw physical strength.
The bodies had abnormally large bite marks,
approximately six times the size of adult
human teeth, yet closer analysis revealed
that the indentations did, in fact, coincide
with human teeth.
Whatever did this possessed more than sixty
teeth, unevenly distributed over six distinct
rows, and required jaws much larger than those
of ordinary humans.
There were unique patterns among these markings,
suggesting that it wasn’t a single entity
that ravaged these corpses, but multiple.
There was no doubt about it, these deaths
were anomalous in nature.
The Foundation issued a designation for the
entities responsible, SCP-3288, and deployed
Mobile Task Force Sigma-6 (“Hellsingers”),
a special unit trained to capture deadly anomalies
in the field, to bring SCP-3288 into Foundation
custody.
The operatives were tasked with patrolling
the Leopoldstadt District, the area where
the most disappearances had occurred.
Secrecy, as usual, was a top priority, and
members of the Task Force took extra care
to conduct their operations away from the
public eye.
As the purpose of this mission was to contain
the entities for further study, the operatives
were also ordered to refrain from lethal force,
and to target SCP-3288 with tracking darts
to prevent them from escaping.
The Task Force divided up their assignments.
Twelve operatives would patrol the district
and search for any suspicious activity, while
ten others would remain watch in positions
with unrestricted views of sewer holes and
other underground access areas.
For the first few hours, things were quiet.
But then, two operatives stationed near the
Danube Canal made a report to the rest of
the team.
Someone near the Canal was screaming, not
loudly, but in a muffled, faint way.
The operatives took initiative and ran off
to investigate the matter themselves, requesting
backup at the same time.
Reinforcements arrived less than three minutes
later, but their teammates could not be found.
Moments later, their bodies were discovered
by another operative, mangled beyond belief.
Both operatives were killed, and alongside
them was the half-consumed corpse of a local
civilian as well.
One operative’s body was recovered from
the canal, while the other was found after
following a trail of blood and fluids into
an alleyway.
But despite the loss of life, the mission
was still deemed a success.
Before being mauled by the SCP-3288 instance,
the Task Force operative managed to shoot
the entity with a tracking bullet, a piece
of technology utilizing satellite location,
which allowed the rest of the team to follow
the entity into the sewers.
The tracking was working perfectly, and the
entity was shown to be fleeing into Vienna’s
sewer system, until the signal faded somewhere
near the Hofburg, a palace constructed centuries
ago that was once host to the Hapsburg Dynasty,
and presently serves as the seat of power
for the President of Austria.
The team was confused, as the fading nature
of the signal suggested that the tracking
bullet had been brought into a location far
deeper than the Viennese sewers were believed
to accommodate.
The mission moved onward, into the depths
of the sewers in pursuit of SCP-3288.
The following day, the Task Force had assembled
a strategy for mapping and exploring the Viennese
sewer system.
Constructed in the mid 19th century, these
sewers were part of a larger
network of subterranean
tunnels that included catacombs, abandoned
wine cellars, and underground rivers.
Without proper planning and clear communication,
death could be a very real possibility, and
not even one caused by SCP-3288.
The task force was divided into four teams
of five.
Three to investigate the sewers and one to
remain on standby.
By triangulating the location of the tracked
instance, the Foundation was able to pinpoint
the general area they would need to explore.
By blocking off certain exits and surface
access points, they hoped to minimize the
possibility of the entity’s escape or exposure
to the public.
While the primary objective remained containing
an SCP-3288 instance for scientific research,
lethal force was authorized to be used in
case of emergencies.
The Foundation valued the lives of its trained
soldiers, and put them above nearly anything.
Still, the authorization of lethal force spelled
impending doom for many experienced veterans
of the task force.
They knew all too well about what kind of
entity they were up against when the Foundation
opted to skip the containment step and prioritize
getting out alive.
A team of operatives reached their destination
safely but didn’t discover
anything of significance
during their trek through the sewers of Vienna,
at least not at first.
After several hours of investigation, they
encountered human skeletal remains while making
their way through waist deep sewage.
One member of the task force pointed out a
loose brick in the wall, and then another
did the same minutes later.
Inspection of the area found
a number of loose-fitting
bricks that were able to be removed with ease,
as if they were put there to hide something.
When the entryway was fully unearthed, it
revealed a previously unseen chamber, whose
walls were engraved with the House of Habsburg’s
coat of arms.
Operatives inside the chamber immediately
knew what they were looking at.
A family crypt of royal bloodline, never uncovered
before.
The forgotten atmosphere made them feel like
they were discovering a secret they were never
supposed to know.
24 sarcophagi were found within the chamber,
and historical records of
the sewers and surrounding
area mentioned nothing about a crypt beneath
the palace.
Multiple statues were recovered from the chamber
as well, depicting veiled women with hushed
expressions, holding a finger to their lips.
Almost as if to say that this place was a
royal secret, and trespassing
had grave consequences
- get it?
“Grave” Consequences…No?
Ooookay…moving on - The tombs themselves
were intricate, decorated with ornate jewelry
and various expensive embellishments, but
did not include placards, markings, or any
indication as to who was entombed within.
When the operatives opened the sarcophagi,
they were disgusted.
The skeletal remains of over 300 bodies, all
displaying severe and likely
fatal birth deformities.
The team was at a loss.
What was the meaning of this room?
The entrance had been destroyed some time
ago, with stairs shattered and buried among
the stone.
Near the other side of the row of tombs was
a vault door, coated in bronze and bearing
the coat of arms of the Habsburgs.
A seal, written in latin, was engraved beneath
the coat.
Translated, it read: “For Purity of Blood”.
The task force tried to pry the door open,
but it wouldn’t budge.
Opening it would require special equipment,
and after what they had witnessed inside the
sarcophagus, some members of the team were
even hesitant to continue trying.
The team was ordered by the supervising team
to hold their location and await the arrival
of another team that would open the door.
Foundation agents on the surface organized
a temporary evacuation of the Hofburg building.
The team waited for backup throughout the
night.
They made attempts to open the vault, but
to no avail.
Once the surface had been properly evacuated
and an infiltration team arrived inside the
chamber to assist with the vault door, the
gate was able to be opened using oxygen-fuel
cutting torches over a period of two hours.
Once opened, the team was met with an ominous,
descending staircase, leading to an unknown,
dark location underneath the palace.
An eight-man squad, heavily armed and equipped
with recording devices, ventured down the
staircase.
Radio transmissions from
the squad grew increasingly
faint over time.
When they reached the estimated 65 meter mark
underground, their communications arrays were
barely audible.
At the bottom of the stairwell was an ornate
foyer.
Instead of decaying, gray stone walls and
oceans of sewage, there were marble floors,
with felted carpets and white painted walls
and ceilings.
This chamber was found to be architecturally
identical to a certain wing of the Hofburg
Palace.
Furthermore, the chamber was clearly built
in the 18th century, as many aesthetic choices
popular during that era were clearly present.
Much like the crypt, there were sculptures
and statues, but this time there were also
columns, paintings, and tattered tapestries.
Some of the operatives admiring the beauty
of the room overlooked that on every piece
of art, any and all depictions of the human
form were defaced and altered.
The air was rancid, with operatives describing
the odor as similar to rotten meat and stale
sweat.
The floor and walls were discolored with what
appeared to be dried, old blood.
Regardless, they moved forward.
In between the space’s equivalent of the
Hofburg Imperial Library was a laboratory,
not found in the palace above.
An operative collected numerous documents
related to alchemy, biology, and the occult,
as well as a journal of transactions, contracts,
and private writings.
These documents were delivered to the above
personnel, and were later translated by Foundation
personnel.
All along this chamber were human remains,
decomposing and strewn around the palace.
Suddenly, a bell tolled, and the music of
a pipe organ began playing discordantly for
over three minutes.
Operatives hid themselves and deactivated
their flashlights, some hiding behind the
curtains of a large opera hall and others
behind large instruments.
They heard footsteps in the distance.
Minutes later, a group of figures emerged
into the palace hall.
The entities the Foundation had classified
as SCP-3288 were now fully visible.
Their outfits were typical of the 18th century,
containing deep shades of red that contrasted
with their stark white skin, porcelain masquerade
masks, and powdered wigs.
Their bodies were monstrous, with arms dragging
across the floor, uneven faces, long fingers,
some possessing more than 10 of, and hunched
backs.
A pair of smaller instances entered behind
the hoard of the others, and one blew a rusted
trumpet while the other held a banner depicting
the Hapsburg’s crest.
The trumpeter began speaking, but its words
were unintelligible, and raw, guttural moans.
They ran out of the way, their stunted legs
causing them to trip across the floor.
There were now over several hundred SCP-3288
instances inside the ballroom.
Multiple operatives activated silent distress
calls, requesting backup to deal with the
mass of entities they would have to contain.
The instances bowed their heads, and another
mass of footsteps were heard as a group of
SCP-3288 instances carried a morbidly obese
instance atop a throne.
It wore a cape, a red veil in place of a mask,
and a crown too small for its head.
It was evident that this was their leader.
A large cauldron was presented before the
king.
A small instance climbed atop the king’s
shoulder and lifted the entity’s veil to
speak to it.
The cauldron was uncovered, and the king lurched
forward, grabbing the tub and pouring its
contents down its massive mouth.
Some of the king’s disgusting meal spilled
from its mouth, revealing a small human child
with severe deformities.
The SCP-3288 instances roared in applause
and began to feast, all while the cacophony
of noise brought on by the various instruments
inside the ballroom raged on.
An operative hiding behind a harpsichord was
discovered by an SCP-3288 instance, and quickly
consumed by it in the feeding frenzy the entities
were engaged in.
Still barely alive before being entirely digested
by the entity, the consumed task force operative
triggered an explosive device from within
the entity’s stomach.
With a look of immediate uncomfort, the entity
suddenly exploded, taking out several other
nearby 3288 instances with the blast.
The entities were distraught, and while they
were distracted, the task force lept into
action and rendered the remaining SCP-3288
instances not killed by the explosion unconscious
using devices loaded with a gas.
As Foundation reinforcements arrived, the
surviving SCP-3288 entities were contained
and moved to Site-282, including the massive
king, whose body was
transported using a specialized
crane.
After the removal of all remaining entities,
the palace was filled with cement and reburied,
with the Foundation making sure that no one
would ever discover it again.
After the King was contained, Foundation personnel
were shocked to discover that the entity could
speak.
In an interview with the hulking monstrosity,
it revealed that its name was Maximillian
the Great, a patriarch of the House Habsburg.
The entity’s eyesight was severely damaged
from centuries of living underground, and
the Foundation was able to get the King to
comply by shining powerful lights in its eyes.
The entity was delusional, believing itself
still to be inside the palace, and referring
to the doctor as nothing more than mere meat,
which it wanted to consume.
When the doctor was able to convince the King
that he too was noble blood, which the king
believed due to his unstable mental state,
the entity uttered a chilling statement:
“We are of the same noble blood.
But some are more noble than others.
Our bloodline is pure - untainted by outsiders.
We do not eat human.
We eat peasants.
We eat undesirables.
We devour life undeserving of life.
That is the nature of nobility.
What else would be the point?”
DNA testing revealed that the king was, in
fact, descended from the House of Habsburgs,
as all SCP-3288 instances were.
But what of the journal entries discovered
inside the palace?
After translation, the Foundation found that
they contained the writings of Leopold I,
a Holy Roman Emperor and member of the Habsburg
house in the early 1700s.
His writings detailed his desire to claim
power over the royal family, as well as his
fears of an increased number of inbred, deformed
members of the Habsburg House.
Leopold details meeting a woman of unknown
origin, who promised him that his family name
could live forever.
She taught him arcane knowledge involving
experimentations of the flesh.
Small animals, and eventually humans were
subject to Leopold’s disgusting, unholy
experiments.
Even his mystical teacher became disgusted
with what her tutelage had wrought.
As payment, she demanded that Leopold cease
his reign, deliver his land and wealth to
common people, and destroy his various deeds
and titles.
Leopold refused, and had the woman burned
at the stake for witchcraft.
Eventually, Leopold’s experiments to make
his bloodline perpetual resulted in the creation
of SCP-3288.
Years of inclusive family ties mutated over
one another, generation after generation,
until a horde of SCP-3288, living underneath
the palace and feasting on a diet of human
meat, were created.
For years, the surface Habsburgs catered to
SCP-3288’s depraved and disgusting needs,
providing them with a slew of humans to feast
on and a lavish lifestyle akin to the one
lived by the nobility above.
One other document revealed to the Foundation
that there were multiple hives of SCP-3288
existing throughout Europe.
Most were discovered and neutralized, but
the original writing was heavily damaged by
mold, meaning that there were some locations
the Foundation was unable to uncover.
Colonies of SCP-3288 instances buried underground,
snatching humans without any care.
Mutating their own deformities and living
horribly, unable to be stopped.
A captured SCP-3288 instance in Germany revealed
that there was another entity, similar to
the King in authority, by the name of the
Empress.
It had this to say to the Foundation, upon
being contained:
“The meek will beget the strong.
The doomed will beget the chosen.
Don't you see?
The greedy will devour the charitable and
the merciless will ravage the peaceful.
We will make the world as perfect as us.
We will all be aristocrats in the end.
And our Dynasty will never die.”
Happy birthday!
It’s your day to enjoy however you want,
with lots of gifts and sweets.
And look - a little friend is here to help
you celebrate.
It’s the birthday monkey, and he has a song
to sing…
Dating back to the 1940s, SCP-983 is one of
the most harmless-looking objects in the SCP
Foundation’s possession.
It’s an old-fashioned mechanical monkey,
a common wind-up toy from the old days.
It’s dressed in a sharp little vest, and
holds a tiny bell and striking rod for making
music.
It seems to be a simple toy, the kind that
would annoy a tired parent as it plays its
little tune over and over, but nothing more.
But this is no ordinary wind-up toy.
SCP-983 is capable of sounds and even speech
that doesn’t seem to match up with its design,
and an investigation reveals it doesn’t
have any signs as to how it was constructed.
No screws, seams, or markings that would be
common on a toy, and no voice box or other
mechanical feature that would allow for speech.
But despite these oddities, it seems to be
a normal toy that can be handled safely and
played with.
On every day but one... that is.
Because SCP-983 has a secondary purpose, and
on one special day it has a gift for its handler.
It can be a gift of joy - or a gift of terror.
Nicknamed the Birthday Monkey, SCP-983 activates
when it is handled by someone
within the twenty-four
hour period of their birthday.
It seems to be able to tell when this period
of time happens automatically, and as soon
as it becomes aware, a series of surprises
begin to surface for the lucky - or unlucky
- handler.
It all starts with a little leap.
As soon as SCP-983 becomes aware of the birthday
boy or girl, it’ll do a charming little
backflip.
It’ll then lift its bell and start singing
the same song - “A Ring Ding Ding Ding It’s
Your Birthday!”
To this day, the Foundation has not been able
to figure out exactly where this voice comes
from, and it follows this by ringing its bell.
The tone of the bell varies wildly - in ways
that the instrument should not be able to
create, ranging from low tones to painfully
high-pitched tones.
And that’s where the horror begins.
The Birthday Monkey doesn’t just want to
sing a song - it wants to play a game.
The song will repeat every three to four seconds,
marked by rings of the bell.
And for every ring of the bell, the birthday
boy or girl will age a year - continuing until
they die of old age, or win the game.
But how does one win the game before it’s
too late?
No one is sure, but studies of this strange
toy in action indicate that it involves singing
along - and timing it correctly.
It’s probably a little hard to do that while
aging to death in seconds, but no one said
SCPs play fair.
But in the event that someone actually does
manage to survive the Birthday Monkey’s
game, it has a prize for them.
When the sing-along is complete, SCP-983 will
let out an enthusiastic shout of “Birthday!”,
ring its bell, and drop a single gumdrop from
its bell.
But which gumdrop depends on just how well
the birthday victim did.
A perfect sing-along will result in a clear
candy that seems to glow.
If it’s a little less than perfect, the
candy won’t glow, but it’ll work the same
- and both candies have a very valuable property.
When eaten, the candy will immediately reverse
any age lost during the “game”.
But does the perfect score give another prize?
Studies of the rare glowing candy led the
Foundation to believe that it may also provide
a bonus effect, making the person who eats
it younger and giving them a longer lifespan
or better health.
But this is largely guesswork, because the
candy is produced so rarely and the effects
would only become clear after years or decades
of study.
But not all candies are to be eaten.
Many candies of different appearance and quality
have been produced.
All can be eaten safely - except the black
ones, which represent a failed sing-along.
The effects of this candy were discovered
the hard way - because the first time SCP-983
was activated, it was activated in the wild,
before the Foundation had secured it.
And everyone knows that an SCP in the wild
can be a terrible thing.
It was a local flea market, when the buyer
noticed the sharp-dressed little monkey.
The buyer, having a friend who loved monkeys,
thought this would be a perfect gift.
The seller was not as enthusiastic, and warned
the buyer that it shouldn’t be handled or
even seen by anyone on their birthday.
But even the seller didn’t really believe
this, saying that it might have just been
an old legend that had been passed down for
years.
It didn’t dissuade the buyer, and off the
monkey went to its new home.
SCP-983 was activated at an office party,
where the monkey was presented as a gift.
The guest of honor loved it at first - until
it started singing.
The staff noticed that as the monkey kept
singing, their co-worker became more and more
upset.
The monkey kept singing, and he started to
search for a way to turn it off - but there
was no button or any other way to deactivate
it.
And that’s when the coworkers noticed something
disturbing.
The honoree seemed to be getting weaker and
weaker, and there were even streaks of grey
appearing in his hair.
His skin was getting more wrinkled and weathered.
Soon his hair was entirely grey, and he simply
returned the monkey to where it was as it
continued to sing.
He seemed to give up, begged for someone to
turn it off, and waited to expire.
By the time the Foundation arrived on scene,
it was already too late.
There was nothing left of the birthday boy
but a desiccated, skeletal corpse.
The monkey had been able to sing at least
thirty more verses, and no
one had truly understood
what was going on.
They reacted with confusion and inaction,
unable to contain the monkey’s dangerous
game.
Even the Foundation didn’t understand SCP-983
at first, so they let the object continue
singing until the body degraded into a simple
skeleton.
That’s when the monkey exclaimed its finishing
phrase and released a single black gumdrop.
While no one ate the gumdrop, the Foundation
observed that it seemed to hypnotize people
around it, as if it was compelling them to
do something.
What is lurking within the black gumdrops
- and do they want to be consumed?
The birthday monkey was taken into SCP custody,
and it became clear that it was harmless to
everyone for 364 days of the year.
The foundation wanted to understand more about
this odd toy, so they fell back on their best
resource for testing - D-class personnel,
who got the chance to show off their singing
skills with much higher stakes than your average
round of karaoke.
Most of the tests were routine, with controlled
activations showing how to deactivate the
monkey - or providing up-close studies of
its devastating effects.
But one test hinted that this specimen could
be more dangerous than thought.
Few people volunteer for testing duty at the
SCP Foundation, but that wasn’t the case
for one now-classified subject.
Her birthday was approaching, and she surprisingly
volunteered for the test that could only be
done on your birthday.
She had an oddly upbeat attitude and seemed
oddly excited about her birthday.
The test was approved, and she was given limited
information.
She was given the monkey as a wrapped gift,
told it would sing, and encouraged to sing
along for a video.
But her reaction indicated she might know
more than expected.
As soon as the gift was unwrapped, the SCP
began singing.
After missing the first verse, the subject
picked up the words and started singing along
- not just competently, but perfectly and
enthusiastically.
Soon enough, she started aging rapidly, but
didn’t seem distressed by this at all.
She maintained her high level of enthusiasm,
even as the monkey sang for over forty verses
and aged her over forty years.
She seemed unaware of these drastic changes,
and never missed a beat of the song until
the monkey issued its finishing exclamation.
And now, it was time for her prize.
The gumdrop that fell from the bell was a
new one, completely white and almost shockingly
bright.
It glowed, and the subject was immediately
enchanted by it.
Even the attending scientists and staff couldn’t
help but comment on how impressive it was.
The subject was allowed to consume it to see
its effects, and was monitored for an hour
afterward.
When nothing unusual happened besides the
reversal of the aging, the subject was excused
to return to her quarters.
And that’s when things took a shocking turn.
In an effect never seen before, the subject
suddenly exploded with a brilliant burst of
white light.
Whatever this light was, it was strong enough
to knock out all the cameras in the vicinity.
Everyone in her presence was temporarily blinded,
with it taking five minutes for their eyesight
to return.
No long-term ill effects were shown, but the
staff that entered the room after the blast
noticed that an odd glow remained in the room.
And that wasn’t the only odd thing.
The test subject was nowhere to be found - and
has never been seen again.
The Foundation is on high alert for this test
subject, but she seems to be staying below
the radar - if she’s even human at all anymore.
While there is no physical sign of her, the
Foundation has observed odd
patterns of electromagnetic
activity in the area and is following reports
of light fixtures needing to be replaced.
It was clear that SCP-983
was much more unpredictable
than expected.
While still classified as safe, the Foundation
is keeping SCP-983 under tighter lock and
key these days.
All technicians who handle it are carefully
vetted to ensure they are nowhere near their
birthday.
In case of accidental exposure, the Foundation
has prepared emergency kits with detailed
instructions for how to complete the Birthday
Monkey’s deadly sing-along game.
But as with all things, the Foundation is
prepared for anything.
In the event of a failure, the remains will
be disposed of by vetted staff.
Any candies produced are to be taken into
custody by the Foundation and studied for
unusual properties, but are not to be consumed
without full containment procedures and approval
from senior staff.
The only exception is D-class testing - but
even in those cases, one rule remains intact.
No one is ever to consume the black candies.
And caution is encouraged around the Birthday
Monkey - lest you wind up in a sing-along
for your life.
From The Garden of Eden to the top corner
of your English teacher’s desk, apples have
played an equal role in history’s most remarkable
days and also its most mundane.
The sounds of teeth snapping through the skin,
sinking into flesh, and spitting out seeds
echo through space forever and onward.
And for most of our earthly hours consumed
by appetite, it has been documented to be
a lopsided relationship between these two
things, man and apple.
Man getting the sweet taste
and abundant nutrients,
apples getting nothing but pain and stomach
acids.
But this story is found not in our history.
Buried in the lawful patterns of predator
and prey, we stumble upon an irregularity,
an inversion, an instance of apples biting
back.
SCP-4608, also known as APPLESEED, was a 60-acre
apple orchard containing over 22,000 trees,
located just on the outskirts of Milan, Indiana
– a town so small it strains your eyes as
you squint to find it with a microscope hovering
just over a map.
And to see what was actually happening within
the curious fringes of society took even greater
exploration, not just of the eyes but also
of the mind.
Because what would eventually be seen would
not so easily be comprehended.
Physical senses are just the surface, and
we need to go deeper.
Our story begins with a logging company looking
to take ownership of the most fertile land
they could find in the Great Lake Region,
ideally land that overproduces conifer growth
so that the return on their investment would
be plentiful and perpetual.
These lumberjacked men knew what they wanted.
Beneath their red flannel shirts and muddy
boots was a deep intelligence and understanding
of nature.
Their process of assessing the land’s value
was meticulously calculated.
They knew the soil, both by the experience
of their callused hands and the literature
of their study.
They tracked various bird species’ migration
patterns in the area to assess what kind of
seeds they’d be carrying and contributing
to soil by way of their stool.
They understood the local laws relating to
clear cutting and conservation and how both
would affect their profit margins.
This is all to say, it wasn’t just a speculative
purchase.
This was planned, thought through, and dwelled
on.
And yet, even then, with scrupulous eyes and
a careful crew, they missed the warning signs.
SCP-4608 checked all their boxes…and then
some.
What could go wrong?
And so they acquired the land, unwittingly
purchasing the peril that came with it.
On the first day of owning the property, one
crew member noticed the branches did not sway
in the same direction as the wind blew.
He noticed the leaves didn’t float down
in agreement with their feathery weight, but
rather crashed to the soil like two-dimensional
anvils and grand pianos.
The roots were not ones you simply trip over,
instead, it seemed as if they stuck their
leg out to trip you.
When birds perched themselves up high and
sang their songs, their cadence carried all
the eeriness of an SOS.
With all of this said, he was happy to have
acquired the land, and having already picked
up and moved his family from the West Coast
to now live and work out in Milan, Indiana,
he decided it best to look past his concerns.
After all, it was the first day on the new
site, and excitement was in the air…but
with it also an amorphous, anxious energy.
During the first logging expedition within
SCP-4608, this same member of the crew hiked
the grounds to better familiarize himself
with the environment he’d be working on,
hopeful that if he managed the land properly
and extracted the lumber as efficiently as
his late father did, he would be able to help
build the business and give his children the
life he always promised them.
He brought with him his notepad and took detailed
records of his surroundings.
He figured to achieve his goals and sustain
long-term yields, he’d have to cooperate
with his environment.
But he never questioned if his environment
wanted to cooperate with him.
Would this question have changed the course
of action?
Or is brooding on the preference of plants
an empty gesture, best left for hippies at
Woodstock?
Either way, the orchard let it be known how
it felt about a collaboration when hours later
the man was found dead.
It was first believed by his coworkers to
be a result of a safety equipment malfunction.
Maybe it was a simple matter of thinking the
skidder was in park when really it was in
neutral.
Maybe the Knuckle-boom Loader went on the
fritz how it does when the humidity ramps
up.
Maybe machinery really was to blame, in which
case you call it a fluke and ask no more.
After all, there’s only so many questions
you can ask a robot.
But initial belief is a fickle thing… and
it wasn’t long until first impressions were
called into question by the courts of critical
thinking.
The questions of the crew, however, only rang
briefly.
Because shortly after the first death fell
a sequence of others.
In a matter of days, all of the remaining
crew members were declared dead or missing,
a word reserved for search parties still clinging
to hope, a hot potato they would have been
wise to abandon.
For while it was hope that brought these search
parties together, it was hope that sent them
off… never to be seen again.
The Foundation was then alerted to the occurrences
surrounding SCP-4608 by police reports accompanied
by a photograph…a photograph of an SCP-4608-1,
an organism consisting of unidentified plant-like
muscular structures and a periderm resembling
those found on common hardwoods.
From the photograph alone, it was clear that
this 3-meter-tall organism was capable of
committing the violence recently endured.
Forceful in its demeanor, aggressive in its
presence, and territorial in its perception,
the photograph of SCP-4608-1 led to an even
bigger question… is this plant-like creature
grown by nature…or sown by man?
After extensive research by The Foundation,
records were retrieved that indicate the entirety
of the sixty-acre land was sown into life
by John Chapman in 1826.
Chapman was the type of man you could mistake
for a scarecrow, both for reasons of preferred
garb and body language.
He was treated as such too.
His personal space was respected…maybe too
much.
He spent his life alone, only accompanied
and comforted by the things he planted.
He maintained these acres all by himself until
his eventual death in 1845, and it’s then
that it’s believed SCP-4608 became unstable,
reassigning its objective from comfort to
chaos.
When the newspaper came out the next Sunday,
John Chapman's obituary painted him as a priest
of the Allen county church.
But was this just the art of illusion?
For as far as we know, no records of a chapel
or congregation exist… a quiet choir indeed.
Come to think of it, it seems that everything
within this sixty-acre orchard was destined
to be silenced one way or another, by violent
force or even by conscious decision making.
See, while the SCP has a long track record
of subduing anomalies by methods of capture
and containment, not all things are suited
for locks and chains.
SCP 4608 is better covered with a story than
a tarp.
A fruitless field that once produced at an
unmanageable pace is now rendered incapable
of supporting growth.
Most will think it’s due to a toxic spill.
In truth, the spill wasn’t that of chemicals
on soil… but rather corpses on crops.
A week after receiving the photograph of 4608-1,
Site-81 sent a three-man investigation team
to Milan.
Their adventure was equally abrupt: a story
with no reportable beginning or middle but
simply a predictable end.
After four days of no
communication, the Foundation
presumed the three agents no different than
their steak dinner, dead meat.
And only then, after The Foundation’s failure
to solve the case, was it understood that
what we were to be looking for wasn’t people
at all…but rather answers to more nebulous
questions.
What’s really happening here?
And why is this happening?
Following the loss of communication with the
investigation team, Site-81 dispatched a high-risk
response team, Mobile Strike Force Bravo-7,
aka Hometown Heroes.
These men had all the makings of heroes, and
they were determined to prove themselves worthy
of that title.
While Alpha squad moved north toward the incident
site, BETA squad headed east and GAMMA squad
hurried west – the crews covering all directions
of the compass but south, a coincidentally
symbolic gesture as if to say we will not
be taken down!
The mission was simple in theory.
Find out what happened to the previous team
and why.
But, alas, missions never are as easy as their
objective statement reads.
In practice, some might even call them…impossible.
As ALPHA headed near the incident site, they
noticed the shadows on the ground beneath
them did not resemble the shape of the leaves
in the canopy above.
They heard small drops of liquid tap tap tap
on their helmets.
Yet, it wasn’t raining… was it?
ALPHA-1 ran his finger across the top of his
helmet and then examined the residue left
on his skin.
It was raining…just not water.
“Oh, god!”
Upon looking up, he witnessed the reasons
for both irregularities.
Bodies hung from branches by their intestines,
casting shadow puppets with their lifeless
limbs.
Blood dripped down like a leaky faucet.
“What did this?”
But before he could even ponder the answer,
he heard a loud shriek from his radio, so
loud that the radio itself vibrated, shaking
its way loose from his hand and falling to
the dirt.
He bent down and picked it up and this time
gripped tighter, as if to tell whoever is
responsible for that noise that they will
not get away that easily.
He and his crew followed the sound like a
game of Marco Polo, blind to what may be ahead.
They extended their guns and pointed them
into the distant tree line, like zombie arms
reaching outward in the pool toward the resonates
of “Polo”, a small comfort in a giant
game of distress.
As they pressed forward, ALPHA Squad proceeded
past all signs that pointed them back, stepping
over dead bodies like puddles on a rainy day.
Soon they found themselves crouching down
next to human remains, attending brief and
hurried funerals for all their closest comrades,
torn between staying to pay respect and marching
along to earn it.
The chest cavities of the fallen had been
ripped open and filled with apples.
A grim foresight into what they were up against.
But nothing they could ever imagine would
prepare them for what they were about to see.
And they wouldn’t have to wait long.
Another loud shriek from ALPHA–1’s radio!
It shot free from his grip and again landed
in the dirt.
The squad tried to ignore the metaphorical
implications of this recurrence, quickly picking
up the radio and shrugging it off as if the
five-second rule applied equally to communication
systems as candy bars.
They pressed forward, maybe out of bravery,
maybe out of shame of going back.
And while moving through trees, they began
to notice something alarming etched on their
bark.
What was it?
There were unnaturally deep grooves on the
base of almost every one of the trees.
But what exactly were they from?
Scratches from an animal or beast?
Infection?
Decay?
Their eyes drew closer.
But proximity brought them no clarity.
These sigils and symbols could be dated back
to occult Norse religion, but in that moment
they were incomprehensible to the men, yet
the message, even if misinterpreted, was very
clear: beware!
Another shrieking cry over the radio.
“The bullets…the bullets aren’t…
they aren’t working.
They can’t.
They can’t penetrate the bark!”
The grass is no greener over on the eastside
of the orchard, where BETA SQUAD gets lunged
at by an 4608-1.
Their defenses are futile, but they fight,
nonetheless, sending rounds to the attacker’s
chest - leading to…
Nothing.
If SCP – 4608 had a health meter, it wouldn’t
have budged in the slightest.
Understanding the negligible impact of their
efforts and assessing their injuries, BETA
SQUAD scurries to retreat to an abandoned
chapel, taking a brief refuge from war only
later to be named.
Quickly, they barricade the door.
In the chapel, Beta-9 tends to BETA-6’s
wounds, who is in the worst shape of them
all: cut, bloody, and beaten.
As he lays there grimacing, he shines his
flashlight up and down the chapel’s walls
until he finds a reason to stop and hold it
steady.
Illuminated is an assortment of human skulls.
And if this wasn’t traumatic enough, he
then spotted apple seeds embedded in BETA-6’s
wounds - Apple seeds that were starting to
sprout.
Beta-9 gave it to him straight.
“This is going to hurt.”
He drew his knife from his belt and lowered
it into his comrades' wounds.
Beta-9 dug into flesh and bone, picking the
seeds out, one by one.
Beta-6’s scream shook the chapel’s stained-glass
windows.
As BETA-1 stood guard, he saw a blur rip past
him, as if life had suddenly been turned up
to three times speed.
He spun around in a circle to try to keep
his eyes on it.
But as his vision refocused, he saw BETA-9
was now dead.
He then shifted his gaze to BETA-6, who was
looking less and less human by the second.
Branches began sprouting out of his body like
an all-consuming magic beanstalk.
Out of his chest.
Out of his eyes.
Out of his mouth.
And when there were no more orifices to exit,
his body exploded, making way for the new
form that had overtaken him.
The barrage of branches broke through the
windows, and the squads fell like dominos.
Dominos not just tapped over gently but kicked
by a toddler on full tilt.
Only two were lucky enough to be on the outskirts
of inertia.
Outside, GAMMA-1 was on his knees thanking
his dead comrade for the grenade he stole
from his back pocket.
“I could always count on you to have my
back.
Even in death.”
One hand holding a grenade and the other on
his radio, Gamma-1 called off Alpha-7: “Alpha-7.
Request for backup rescinded.
Go grab a burger.
I’ll take it from here.”
Gamma-1 slowly glanced up and locked eyes
with SCP-4608-2, a large apple tree with 13
human faces embedded into it, a perennial
plant with great powers, a gymnosperm that
has found a voice.
Blood poured from SCP – 4608 – 2’s empty
eye sockets.
Gamma-One smirks: “Get some eye drops, sicko.”
He crawled over to the beast.
The faces begin yelling at him in indescribable
tongues.
“Let me refer you to a speech therapist,”
he jokes as he pulls the pin of the grenade
and throws it toward the largest of the thirteen
mouths.
SCP – 4608-2 chokes on the grenade, forcing
it to inhale deeply… the strength of its
lungs pulling Gamma – 1 toward it and sucking
him in.
The grenade goes off.
SCP-4608-2 explodes.
The surrounding trees scream and combust.
The orchard goes up in flames, the bodies
of the fallen are given an appropriate cremation.
Gamma–1’s radio lay face up on the dirt.
A voice rattles it awake.
It’s Alpha–7.
“Gamma–1.
Gamma-1, you there?
Can you hear me?
Please.
Please, Gamma -1?”
On October 16, 1947 ALPHA-7 was recovered
by the Allen County Fire Department, unconscious
and suffering from exhaustion
and smoke inhalation.
The Site-81 Concealment Team took control
of the situation and quarantined the area
using the cover story of a toxic chemical
hazard.
Following debriefing and a
psychological evaluation,
ALPHA-7 was administered amnestics and switched
to low-risk recovery assignment.
The members of MTF Bravo-7 were posthumously
awarded the Foundation Star for their efforts
during the neutralization of SCP-4608.
And so, the one question that remains is…
how?
How did SCP -4608-1 become so dangerous, and
how did its danger slip by for so many years?
Is its volatility by nature,
design, or consequence?
Could it be that the Foundation failed to
understand the complexity of this creation?
During Chapman’s lifetime, there were no
accidents or fatalities coming from SCP – 4608.
Yet, there is no reason to believe that SCP
– 4608 -1 wasn’t always capable of harm.
Maybe it always was capable of mass murders,
but simply had no reason to kill.
What if the logging company never stepped
foot on that land?
Never brought out their sharp blades and heavy
machinery?
What if this perilous orchard was in fact
docile, but provoked?
What if the proverbial tree only falls in
the woods when we force our philosophy on
it.
Though SCP -4608-2 spoke in unidentifiable
sounds, the noises were always recognized
and recorded as language.
It spoke with intent, even if misunderstood.
What it screamed is still unclear.
Were they pleas for help?
Or messages of hate?
And would one even be worse than the other?
John Chapman might argue, when facing heavy
machinery and trained artillery, would raising
your voice even be a moral decision at all?
Is fight or flight imbued not just in blood…
but also in bark?
The ‘devil on your shoulder’, your ‘guardian
angel’; these are expressions that we’ve
all heard countless times.
Of course, they’re not supposed to be taken
literally.
None of us have a heavenly spirit looking
over us and protecting us from harm, in the
same way that nobody really
has a little red-skinned
imp whispering encouragement to commit atrocious
deeds in someone’s ear.
They’re metaphors: guardian angel refers
to any instance of seemingly divine intervention,
but is more often a coincidence that ends
up benefitting a person when they need it
most.
And the devil on your shoulder, that’s temptation,
the little voice in the back of your head
that sometimes eggs you on to do something
you know you shouldn’t.
But what if there was a being that was both,
a demonic, malicious creature that also acted
as a guardian for someone unable to protect
themselves?
Is it even possible for a being to be both
angel and devil?
And who out there could ever qualify for such
holy and hellish protection?
Ombre Rouge was once a fairly normal place
to live.
A small Louisiana town in one of the smallest
of these fifty United States.
Its name was derived from the French language,
translating to ‘Red Shadow’, an ominous
name for a township that was otherwise so
uninteresting and forgettable.
In fact, if things had never panned out the
way they had, Ombre Rouge would have stayed
that way, just a place where nothing interesting
ever happened.
All of that changed, of
course, when the disappearances
started.
For anyone who might be too young to remember
them, the mid-2000s were a turbulent time.
The Iraq War was in full swing, and a nationwide
financial crisis was rapidly approaching.
But, in the midst of all this global chaos
and instability, the residents of Ombre Rouge
were soon to be caught in the thralls of their
very own shared torment.
At first, like with most bad things, it started
small.
One person went missing,
an unfortunate occurrence,
but not exactly unheard of.
Sadly, these things happen, especially when
you live so close to the swamplands of Louisiana.
People wander out into the marsh, under the
searing heat of the sun,
only to suffer heatstroke,
collapse, and end up buried in the dark, dank
mud, never to be seen again.
Few of those living in the town took much
notice of the first disappearance.
Apart from the missing person’s relatives,
many just shrugged off the news; as sad as
it was, most of the townsfolk were just grateful
it hadn’t happened to any of their own family
or friends.
Maybe it was that ignorance, that lack of
vigilance or reaction, that meant a second
resident would also be reported missing, not
long after the first.
But this time was different: unlike the previous
disappearance, this one had an eyewitness.
Clement Donovan – known to locals as ‘Clem’
– had spotted a passer-by while taking out
bags of garbage.
This unassuming pedestrian was the second
disappearance victim.
Thinking little of the man, who just seemed
to be walking home, Clem went back inside.
A split second later, he heard a scream from
outside and rushed back to his dimly-lit porch.
It was there that Clem claimed he saw… something
retreating towards the nearby woods.
However, Clem’s wild story of something
not quite human wasn’t taken seriously by
local police.
He’d even managed to snap a grainy photo
on his clamshell cell phone, but back in 2005,
phone cameras were nowhere near as advanced
as they are today.
Most Ombre Rouge locals wrote Clem off as
a crazy old man at best.
But at worse, it made him look like someone
who was trying to exploit or make light of
the disappearances, something that garnered
him a lot of dirty looks from his neighbors.
That was, until a number of other residents
started reporting they had also witnessed
a humanoid creature.
It’s hard to say if any of these eyewitnesses
were genuine, and how many were just people
latching on to Clem’s story.
Regardless, the disappearances hadn’t stopped
and it didn’t take long
for an unknown organization
to roll into Ombre Rouge after hearing the
rumors of a creature sighting.
A few residents, even the local sheriff’s
department, thought these shady figures were
a division of forensic specialists here to
aid in the investigations into the missing
persons.
The more conspiratorial folks living in the
town had a different explanation, that the
newcomers were a deep state-controlled, top-secret
government group, there to assess the possibility
that there really was some kind of monster
on the loose.
Not long after this group had arrived in Ombre
Rouge, the number of residents going missing
seemed to dwindle.
On the eighteenth of December 2005, they packed
up and left town, giving no explanation to
the local police.
Nobody knew if this secretive ‘Foundation’
had actually uncovered the perpetrator responsible
for all the disappearances, if there even
was any creature like the rumors said.
But whatever had transpired in that Louisiana
swamp town, one thing was clear: the moment
the Foundation left, nobody else went missing
from Ombre Rouge.
Or at least, not for over a decade.
Before then, however, little else of note
happened in Ombre Rouge after the initial
spate of missing person cases.
That is, apart from a car accident that took
place just under a year after the various
disappearances ended.
A heavily-injured man by the name of Simon
Hays was taken to a local hospital, suffering
from a severe concussion.
Simon had been involved in a collision with
a car on the eleventh of November 2006.
The doctors that examined him determined that
Simon had been left with short-term retrograde
amnesia, a condition that affected all his
memories from prior to the accident.
It was due to this that he was unable to recall
events that occurred in the years before he’d
sustained his injuries.
Now, what is it that makes
a random, if unfortunate
car accident victim so significant?
Well, Simon Hays actually became the first
person in Ombre Rouge to be declared missing
in almost a decade.
In 2016, ten years after his accident and
eleven after the original slew of disappearances,
Simon vanished when returning to his hometown
in Louisiana to visit his family.
Naturally, Simon Hays wouldn’t be the last
familiar face to return to the town.
A repetition of such similar
and strange occurrences
as before also brought the mysterious Foundation
rolling back in.
Little did the townsfolk know, in the year
that had followed the group’s original exodus
from Ombre Rouge, they had lost something.
On the exact same day Simon suffered his accident,
whatever it was the Foundation had left town
with had managed to escape.
Perhaps this was a purely coincidental occurrence,
but what if it wasn’t?
After all, road traffic collisions take place
all the time, all over the world.
But an accident happening in a town with a
history of people going missing, on the exact
same day that this… thing escaped captivity?
Maybe there was a link between these two events.
At the very least, the Foundation seemed to
think so.
Some of the more astute people living in the
swamp-side town noticed black, armored transport
vehicles moving into their neighborhoods,
men in body armor locking down the whole of
Ombre Rouge.
These didn’t seem like local police, they
weren’t even the National Guard, although
they were certainly heavily armed enough to
cause concern.
This unit of specially trained operatives
quickly took control of the entire township,
their authority never questioned by the sheriff’s
department.
The place was small enough,
isolated by surrounding
swamps and marshland, that it was easy for
Mobile Task Force Epsilon-6 to get away with
an operation like this.
Before the people of Ombre Rouge had time
to argue, the Task Force had already begun
their investigation.
The newest series of disappearances had started
in 2016 with Simon Hays mysteriously vanishing,
and had continued two years later in 2018.
Just like the first spate back in 2005, there
were sporadic and unconfirmed eyewitness accounts
of a creature, shaped like
a human but considerably
taller, almost two meters in height.
Most witnesses reported only ever seeing this
local bogeyman at night time, making it much
harder to see in detail, although a few seemed
to state its skin was deep red, unlike any
natural human skin tone.
While before, residents of the Louisiana swamp
town had brushed off stories like this as
nothing more than rumors and urban legends,
the Foundation seemed pretty receptive to
the idea of some kind of monster on the loose
in the marshland.
And after all, they had good reason to believe
such an outlandish story… because it was
the same creature that had already escaped
from them in 2006.
Continuing their investigation into the link
between Simon Hays and this creature, Mobile
Task Force Epsilon-6 – also known by the
codename the ‘Village Idiots’ – arrived
at Hays’ place of residence.
Kicking the door down, breaching the house,
they began a room-by-room sweep, looking for
any clues that would explain why the monster
they’d captured escaped on the same day
as Simon’s accident.
One of the MTF operatives uncovered something,
an envelope stashed in the home Simon had
grown up in.
He opened it cautiously, a collection of papers
that were contained inside came spilling out.
They were a series of simple drawings on paper
that seemed to be more than a few years old.
The crudeness of the hand-scrawled pictures
and age of the paper seemed to imply they
had been created by a child.
A number of the drawings depicted the same
thing: a red-skinned creature, just like the
one the townsfolk had reported seeing.
With them was a note, written by Simon’s
mother, which read:
“Found these old drawings of yours.
Thought you might like to see them again.
Welcome home.”
There was a link, an unclear, maybe tangential
connection but one that was growing the more
information the Foundation uncovered.
Whatever this being was, a very young Simon
Hays had seen it while growing up in Ombre
Rouge.
Due to the short-term retrograde amnesia that
he’d sustained after his accident, he wouldn’t
have remembered it, but perhaps this… thing
remembered him.
Did that mean the pair of them might be linked
somehow?
Not just by coincidence, but some kind of
connection that allowed the creature to escape
its captivity on the exact day Simon had his
car accident.
A connection that had drawn Hays back home
to Ombre Rouge, or drawn the beast to Simon
to kidnap him.
Moving fast, MTF Epsilon-6 began to rapidly
sweep the remainder of the town, searching
for any further signs that would lead them
to the whereabouts of either Simon Hays or
this elusive, crimson-skinned bogeyman.
They interviewed residents and chased cold
leads, before eventually backing their target
into a corner.
The Foundation’s MTF operatives mapped the
location of every eyewitness report of the
creature, using that information to track
it back to a possible point of origin.
It was a barn, left abandoned, practically
falling apart as it stood in a state of disrepair
just outside the small Louisiana town.
Under the cover of darkness, the task force
approached the wooden structure, weapons locked
and loaded, keeping them trained on the barn.
Cautiously moving closer, remaining on high
alert, the squad activated their night vision.
There was the low, almost undetectable sound
of movement coming from within the barn.
Slowly, the MTF’s leader pushed open the
wooden door and peeked inside.
It was there he saw what they had been looking
for, the thing that had escaped the Foundation
over ten years before: SCP-3631, a Man and
his Monster.
The beast was just over six feet tall, its
skin a bloody shade of crimson just as some
of the eyewitnesses had described.
It sported a pair of arms and bipedal legs,
giving it a humanoid shape.
However, that was exactly where its likeness
to human beings ended.
The creature, later designated as SCP-3631-1,
lacked eyes, ears, or a nose, only a wide,
gaping maw of sharp teeth.
Its face was covered in holes that twitched
and puckered like smaller, miniature mouths.
In actuality, it used these orifices for various
senses; it smelled, saw, and detected sounds
through the holes in its otherwise mostly
featureless face.
As the members of MTF Epsilon-6 entered the
barn stealthily, making sure not to alert
SCP-3631-1, they sighted something else.
Someone else was in the barn with it, a man,
not a dead victim or another monster like
SCP-3631-1, but an actual, living, breathing
human man.
MTF Epsilon-6’s commander gave his squad
the signal to engage.
Hearing the sounds of weapons cocking around
it, the creature turned and snarled, crawling
on all fours like an animalistic predator.
At first, it reared back, It wasn’t until
one member of the task force approached that
SCP-3631-1 retaliated, attacking the Foundation
operatives in a frenzy.
Following a prolonged and bloody exchange,
MTF Epsilon-6 managed to subdue the creature
and were able to once again return it to
Foundation
captivity.
But this time, unlike back in 2005, they had
SCP-3631-2 as well.
As the red monster was prepped for transport,
a survivor of the task force noticed something:
an ID, perhaps a driver’s license, on the
man’s person.
The Epsilon-6 operative picked the card up,
wiping away smears of blood with a gloved
finger, enough to reveal a single, familiar
name printed on it…
Simon Hays.
Before long, just like last time, the Foundation
rolled back out of Ombre Rouge, leaving the
Louisiana townsfolk none the wiser about what
had happened there.
Little did they know the ‘Red Shadow’
hanging over their home had been lifted.
But it had come at the cost of a number of
disappearances that would remain unsolved,
people who would never be found, families
forced to go on without ever getting answers.
When he was returned to the Foundation’s
labs, SCP-3631-2 was sent
for extensive examination.
Given the severity of the
invasive organ transplants
he’d undergone, it was impossible to tell
if he was, in fact, Simon.
The creature had been regularly replacing
the man’s internal organs, on a monthly
basis whenever they showed signs of decay
or failing.
Somehow, despite the high risk of blood loss
and infection posed by this crude form of
surgery, the subject had remained alive.
But he was unable to speak, conscious but
showing very limited responses to stimuli.
Nobody knows why the carnivorous, nocturnal
monster SCP-3631-1 took this man captive.
In the same vein, it is unclear why the creature
felt such a need to protect him, going to
such lengths as hunting for replacement organs
from unwilling donors.
Perhaps, in a grisly, twisted way, SCP-3631-1
was the man’s guardian angel.
Or maybe more a devil on his shoulder.
I wonder, is it really possible for something
to be both?